learn advanced music production with FL
Studio in this course from Tristan
Wilcox Tristan is a professional music
producer with over 10,000 hours in music
production in this course you'll learn
complex techniques that will transform
your approach to cing music Tristan
covers everything from mastering plugins
and sound design to understanding the
subtle differences between being a music
artist and a music producer in my first
FL Studio beginner tutorial I taught you
guys how to make your very first
beginner track and I didn't assume that
you knew anything I basically did the
tutorial as if you had never heard of
anything music production related and
that you've never seen the software
before in this tutorial I'm going to be
assuming that you have made your own
songs before you have been using FL
Studio and if you're coming here for the
first time and you do want to learn
music production but you don't know
anything about it yet I would highly
suggest that you go watch some uh good
beginnner tutorials and I have made a
very in-depth one that is also on this
channel so if you watch that one first
You' be uh greatly prepped for uh this
one once you want a more advanced
in-depth look with this tutorial what
I'm going to be doing is it's going to
go a little bit differently um and
rather than make a track uh because
tracks that are in my estimation like
Advanced I put in 40 to 50 hours into
any given track and obviously that would
be just a little bit too long for a full
length YouTube production and while I
hope I could record that one day I think
the editing would be extremely tedious
so uh for now what I'm going to do is
I'm actually just going to go over some
categories of Advanced Techniques that I
think I could cover in a more realistic
time frame so you guys can still get the
benefits of having an advanced knowledge
of music production without uh the price
tag of having to watch something that
would actually take that that
[Music]
length um something to know and this is
going to be the very first thing so even
if you don't watch the rest of this
tutorial you at least get one of
probably the most valuable tip you'll
get um or you know what I'll give you
two you're lucky today um the first one
is that uh you have to love the process
of music production if you don't like it
you're never going to be a a truly
Advanced producer or an artist in my
estimation um my definition of an artist
um I don't know what the actual
definition is I should probably look it
up but the one that I have written down
here is that an artist is someone who
can take a story idea or emotion and
express it through sound um and I know
it sounds extremely basic but the idea
is that I have some idea or some pattern
in my mind and I can like I have it
there and I want to get it from here to
onto the screen like that's that's what
I want to do or I guess into the
headphones not on the screen but you get
the point and the software is just
helping me accomplish that task so that
is what I think an artist is a music
producer the difference between music
producer and artist a music producer
just knows how to use the software okay
and that's not anything too remarkable
like anybody can learn anything with
enough time and effort making music is a
completely different thing and I think
that that's why I'm really happy the
first beginner tutorial I decided to
teach you guys how to make music because
that's different than learning music
production you see what I'm saying so
that's one tip is that if you don't know
the differences between music production
and actually being a music artist you
might be trying to develop the wrong
things uh so for for instance like if
you just think oh I just need to learn
more of about music production and then
I'll be a better artist I mean you could
be sending yourself on an infinite
Journey that you'll never finish because
being a better artist is a completely
different skill set than being a music
producer um it's about what the what can
make you better at getting the ideas
from your head on into the program
rather than learning more about the
program so yeah that's that's one thing
the second thing and it does have to do
with uh loving the process is that you
want to constantly be asking yourself
questions in life the like the what is
it called um just adding things you're
like oh this would sound cool if I did
it like this or what if I use this like
this or what if I use this in a way
that's not supposed to be used or just
you're trying new things you're trying
to like uh you're always constant
basically you're having fun that's
that's basically what I'm trying to say
you're having fun while making music if
you're not having fun while you're
making music then if it's not enjoyable
I it's going to be really hard to make
something good out of it and if even if
you do make something that's a good
production it may not really have an
emotional connection with the listeners
so those are two things that I think
that already will help you just speed up
the process of you becoming Advanced
producer because if you spend time
working developing skills that you don't
need obviously that's going to waste
your time so you want to be focused on
exactly what you want if you want to
just do music production you don't care
too much about making your own music
then sure learn the software as much as
you possibly can but if you're looking
to become an artist that's more the
people I'm talking to because that's the
Practical use for why you'd want to
learn to make music in the first place
so with that being said uh let's get
into some more um advanced music
production techniques that can help you
as an
artist so uh first things first I'm just
going to show you guys um something
pretty cool if I open up basically any
plugin here um and by the way I'm using
all free plugins so you guys can
completely follow along with me if I
just open up fidal for instance this is
a great synthesizer if you guys are
familiar with serum this is a very
similar synth and it's completely free
and I think it's I think it's amazing so
if I just click on the plugin here and
then just contr L this is a I'd say this
is an intermediate technique but uh if
you click control L it automatically
puts it on the mixer as you can see it
names it for you and it colors it and
puts it on the nearest mixer that isn't
already taken
so and obviously the reason of why this
is useful is is immediately evident if
you've ever used F studio for organizing
because what happens is you're like okay
well I have to go here and then I have
to go to my channel rack and I have to
put it on a mixer and then once I get it
on that mixer I have to rename the mixer
and you have to do all this stuff but
just doing control L it does it all for
you so I mean obviously that's going to
be faster a lot more efficient so right
there that's just going to help you keep
track of where your instruments are and
where they are in your mix so just an
organizational tip right there um the
second thing is is that um and this is
just uh for all those people who wanted
a sound design course you're welcome I'm
going to go over the basics of sound
design uh because I didn't do that in my
beginner course and I think that a lot
of you were interested in that so uh
let's focus on the basic principles that
will underly basically all music
production uh sound design your attack
delay sustain and release okay now
attack uh basically this is think of
this as a volume over time okay so what
does that mean well for example why
don't we just play the note and see what
happens you can see that we can follow
this line and see what's going on so the
it's almost like a graph so the higher
on the graph the more volume the lower
on the graph the less volume further to
the left is closest to us in time and
then further to the right would be in
the future so you can see what what's
happening over time to the the volume of
the sound so what attack is going to do
you can almost visualize it in your head
but also explain it can help uh you can
see that it's going to start off lower
volume go up in high volume and then
come back
down okay so that's what attack does
Decay you can see how it affects the
tail of the
sound you can see the sustain is going
to you might be like what what does this
do let's
see okay so if you hold the note the
sustain actually will hold it at this
volume it will never go lower than the
than the what whatever this is saying is
at it'll hold it at that volume until
you let go of the note when you let go
of the note the tail at the end this
little
release that's what happens after I let
go of the note the rest of it that plays
is your release so what this is
typically called is your adsr attack
Decay sustain and release and sometimes
you have some extra ones like hold hold
is an extra one that's not on all
synthesizers but it is on some and then
delay which is uh your more fancy
synthesizers will have this not all of
them do um and obviously you can see
kind of based off of what it did to the
visual you can tell what it would do
like soundwise but if you can just know
this you can make all kinds of sounds so
first of all I can make
pluck or I guess chords uh if I want to
move the attack down I can make more
[Music]
pluck if I wanted more of a chord I
could add a little bit of attack and
then maybe a little bit more
Decay if I wanted to add a more Super
thing you could have it have high
sustain so so there's lots of options
here um and depending on which genre
you're making it's going to affect the
adsr of the sounds that you're actually
using so for instance synth wave they
have like very long release a very long
Su or very high sustain and kind of hard
attack so it's like a very lengthy drawn
out
stuff also I don't know music theory so
don't judge my piano playing skills um
so basically that's that's the
fundamental that's the most fundamental
sound production I can give you the
second part is we have our uh oscillator
so oscillator is going to be What wave
table it's playing over and over and
over again so um if you click the 2D and
3D you can see the different views of
the oscillator so I have this let's go
to a different one so I can show you
guys really what's going on here so
that's the 3D view I mean that's the 2D
this is the 3D view it's scrolling
through the through the thing and then
this is the uh side view it's pretty
cool it it kind of shows you what is
happening to the wave table as you
scroll through it and just scrolling
through it I just left click and drag up
down or you can drag this not so uh
let's just do some basic sound design
things so this let's make
a more of a synth wav is excuse me let's
make more of a synth wav is uh type
thing so let's use this wave table
because it looks pretty cool and I'm
going to start here I'm going to drag
this envelope you see this is envelope
one the one that we're working on if I
go to a different tab it's going to
change so it's like envelope one drag it
onto this uh the thing that was changing
the wave tape
okay so now what
happens it's pretty interesting so it's
actually taking the input of this and
applying it to this um what's it called
this um knob so you can do this All and
by changing this knob right here it
changes the
way you can see how I'm using the the
attack uh okay hold on let me say this
correctly the envelope of this is sh is
working on this knob in the exact same
pattern okay and it's basically changing
the the wave table so it's it's one of
those things that like more of like
after you do things a lot you kind of
know what they do and what you're trying
to accomplish but it's harder to explain
like in words what's going on and
honestly I think that the wordy
definitions aren't the most useful
things in mustion anyways it's just like
hey here's this technique you can use
this and learn it so uh without overe
explaining everything uh another thing
you can do is if you turn this knob the
opposite direction and this works in a
lot of these type of plugins uh is it'll
actually go the opposite way
so okay so we have some cool there I'm
going to turn up the Unison so what this
is going to do is it's going to play the
same uh the same wave table multiple
times at different uh slightly different
painting and slightly different uh
pitches
and by dragging down the dtune it's
dragging down the panning and the uh the
tuning of the separate wave tables to be
closer together uh less detuned and less
further right and
left so we have something like that so
right off the bat we just have one one
uh what is it called wave table playing
with just a little just one envelope
okay now you could see how you get so
complicated with music production
because you could add another uh another
wave table here you could add another
oscillator playing a different wave
table and that could have its own
envelope so I could have this have a
completely different envelope put that
on maybe the the
[Music]
volume
you can see just by using different
envelopes and different things you can
come up with completely uh really
interesting uh like sounds just by
adding multiple oscillators and multiple
uh envelopes and you don't need to get
that complicated uh you can make really
good sounds just with one just like I
was showing you before so even just with
this uh we're just in the oscillator
section right here of vital and there's
lots of things you can work with this
there's
filters and these filters you can also
automate with the envelope so like
basically just think of this you can
drag this envelope anywhere you can drag
a lot of these knobs like all over the
place and just be automating and
changing everything over time and do
some crazy stuff and you might be
extremely overwhelmed but the fun part
is it's all just experimenting and
seeing what stuff does and what sounds
good and then over time just by messing
around and having that Spirit of I want
to see what this does and it might break
my project over and over again you'll
start to very slowly see the connections
between different plugins and see the
see the patterns in them so I don't
think it's really helpful for me to go
through every what every single thing in
this plugin does but rather give you the
principles that allow you to go through
many different plugins and understand
the basics of each of them so the first
uh principle that we went over was
attack Decay sustain and release uh the
second that we went through was the idea
of wave tables that change over time um
obviously our basic Unison and uh Dune
and then we have pitch which is pretty
self-explanatory he's just going to
change the p uh pitch up a note and then
this is like the fine tuning of pitch
and then uh our level which is just
going to be the amplitude of the of the
signal uh I showed you that we can add
in different uh oscillators and wave
tables that you can even apply filters
before it goes to the effects and last
but not least I guess I'll show you the
voices over here so in the bottom right
hand corner uh as you can see you can
change the amount of voices that are
playing so if I or I mean that are
allowed to play so if I just play one
and I try playing another note it's
going to switch to that note and it
won't let me play chords anymore because
the max amount of voices I'm allowing is
one which means that it's going to be
just a lead instrument you might say
Tristan why would you want to do this
well suppose I want to have my notes
slide between each other I could turn up
the Glide and I could turn up the slope
a little bit just to affect the way it
Glides I can maybe hit Legato and now
when I have just my one note and I play
them uh play another
[Music]
note I could have a completely different
style of sound just because I'm limiting
it to one voice so it has to slide
between the notes uh like and that's
just an interesting thing that you could
do and maybe you want to turn this off
and then you don't want to Glide and you
want to turn up the voices I have
chords so just different ways of working
so or it depends on what you want
um macros uh this is important so a
macro you can control a bunch of
different things and then have it all
one knob controlling all of this so this
knob doesn't do anything on its own but
it allows you to control many effects at
the same time so let's say if I want to
change uh a bunch like if I have one
type of sound but then if I turn this
macro up it affects a bunch of these
knobs you could create a second version
of that sound just uh based of How High
this is up or down um next Advanced
thing that you you can know is you any
knob that you turn in almost any plugin
in FL Studio even third party plugins
can be automated so if I turn this macro
up and down and then go to this knob up
here and click right click you'll see
that it says create automation clip if I
just click that it'll create an
automation clip and then literally if I
just drag this up and down and we go
back and we play this over and over and
then go back to
vital you'll see it's it's actually
moving the macro in my uh plugin based
off of this Automation and I and it
works in real time I hold on I need to
put this to attached so I can show you
guys
so that is like just so cool it it works
so fast and you like can do things on
the fly like as it's happening it's so
helpful to do this kind of stuff so uh
and automations are huge so you think
that um maybe you don't want something
to be changed within the plugin itself
you can actually change it through
automations out here and that could
essentially act as
yeah like a separate controller for it
uh outside of your uh VST and that that
could be super helpful so like if you're
making a song and I want the volume of
the instrument to be low on maybe the
sine wave here I have it really low in
the beginning of the song but as the
song progresses I have this turning up
over time just some things to think
about just some ideas I can give you um
so this is only the first section of the
plugin and I didn't even go through all
of it I didn't go through lfos lfos are
pretty cool I guess I'll show you those
really
fast so this is affecting the volume but
it Loops over and over again so if I
turn the frequency
up you can see kind of what's happening
it's basically going through the playing
it's like an envelope right here like
the same adsr thing but then imagine
that it restarts and plays it again
after it gets to the
end and then we can change the different
uh
Mo uh excuse me change the different
modes so if I go to like
sync oh maybe it's not sink hold
on uh oh my bad I'm being silly it's um
it would
[Music]
be
SI you could do some clever things like
that where uh it the way that it Loops
is differently so sometimes you can Loop
it based off of the the grid that you
have in FL Studio so it will Loop like
uh one beat uh one step like and then
like you know just I don't know what the
names are for it but then this would go
based off a time so it could actually be
offbeat with the song so many cool
things you could do here um if you ever
want to take something off though uh all
you have to do is right click and click
disconnect from lfl1 or you can go to
the lfl that is connected to it and you
disconnect from oscillator one and it
will give you a list of all things that
things are connected to so you can like
disconnect things from where they're
connected to um and this is also a bunch
these are also really cool this has to
do with like how you're playing like on
your piano uh this will affect like the
the the notes and Stu there's so many
cool things in this PL I I could spend
so time on all this stuff but we're just
I want to keep moving too because
there's just so much to cover okay uh
effects so with effects uh this is
basically think of this you have your
your wave table uh your oscillator
playing a wave table it's uh going
through the envelope it might be going
through a few filters that signal is
going to move on and go to this next
section called effects and then whatever
you do in here is applied after this
section right here so these go like in
succession so now you have I can add
chorus and it will'll apply to that
sound we had from before
oh my bad the level's off that's why
because we had the LFO and it was
controlling the volume so I have to turn
this back
up um just for sake of uh you guys not
listen my piano playing uh let's uh put
in a midi a midi from one of my midi
packs so just that you guys have
something to listen to that's not
completely
terrible let's play something that's a
little bit more drawn
out
[Music]
okay this is cool so we'll play this
we'll turn the attack down just slightly
and then we'll start uh just you know
like making some cool idea so what we'll
do is I'll add maybe just a tad bit
Distortion just a little bit and this
will just add just a little
crispiness not that
much just ever so slightly I just want
it to sound like it's kind of like
beaten up a little bit and then we'll
add a little post to that Distortion and
what that'll do is it'll just cut any
[Music]
he so got some really like epic synth
wave action going on so we have uh let
me just go through each one of these so
we have filter uh this is just the same
thing as what this does but it's just a
your a separate thing I guess it's just
if you don't want to use the Distortion
you can just use this filter um EQ it's
exactly what it sounds like it's just
your standard EQ that you know just does
does the thing um it I feel like okay uh
let me just say this right off the bat I
might sound like I'm going too fast but
if you are a beginner watching this
obviously none of this will make any
sense but if you're in advanced or if
you're looking to become an advanced
producer in you're an intermediate stage
then you should know what an EQ is by
now so I don't I shouldn't have to
explain it if you don't know what an EQ
is then you probably should spend more
time on the beginner tutorial and maybe
make a few of your own songs and
eventually you figure out what an EQ is
and then you come back anyways so I just
don't want to be too boring for people
who already know what this stuff is
because I know that if I explained
literally everything like I thought adsr
was a little bit too slow for explaining
but hopefully that's helpful for
somebody you okay flinger uh I can't
tell you what this does but it does a
thing
[Music]
[Applause]
to me a flinger and a phaser feel like
they're doing the same thing with
different uh what would it be called
like different sound it's different
sounds of the same thing that's kind of
my take I it even looks like they're
doing the same thing I'm not sure what
they're doing uh I think it has
something to do with the phase uh don't
ask it's something pretty complicated
but all I know is it can sound cool but
sometimes it really messes up your
master so lots of produc producers will
avoid using a flinger and a phaser
because they don't want it to affect
their mix too much um Reverb uh very
cool the Reverb in this is it's all
right it's not
[Music]
bad
I mean the reeverb isn't anything insane
like maybe aala super massive or
something uh we could add that or
convolver or my favorite ROM ROM is the
best Reverb uh it was free I don't know
if it's free anymore I got it when it
was free it was on some promotion uh
this is a fantastic Reverb if you were
looking for a good Reverb and you're I
think I don't know if it's like 40 50
bucks this is completely worth it uh and
I listen there there some plugins that
I'm like okay there are it's hard to
come by good reverbs let me just say
that like so this is this is a good
Reverb like if you're looking for a good
Reverb highly recommend this
one it just sounds so good oh my
goodness okay anyways I'm going to stop
ging at uh the ROM uh so different
effects what did I miss compressor of
course this is a OT t uh is the same
thing as this so if you if you guys are
familiar I need to turn off the attach
this is annoying okay if you guys have
used OT uh it's just this plugin right
here this is so popular uh OT it's a
it's a up and down compressor so
downwards
compressor um basically imagine you have
like a line okay and a compressor as you
bring down that line and then whatever
the what's it called like the waveform
if it went above that line it would just
squash it under that line and compress
that sound now the what happens with a
upwards compressor is it does the exact
opposite and I love upwards compressor
what it does is I have a line and let's
say
my uh I have like a waveform whatever
doesn't go to that line it's going to
get lifted up to that line that's the
way I understand it so it lifts up the
low points and a compressor uh does the
opposite or downwards compressor does
the opposite brings the high points down
uh so that's the difference I yeah I
can't completely tell you if that's
correct but I'm like 9% % sure that
that's like about what's going on on a
very basic
level by the way if you're wondering I
think OT sounds better than the Ott in
vital I'm sorry I don't know why but uh
this Ott is it's it's it's all right
it's pretty
[Music]
good it still sounds better with it I
think
[Music]
Okay cool so I pretty much went over the
basics of sound design and I would say
that this get got a little bit into the
advaned ter territory uh not not quite
there but the thing is is that I taught
you how to become Advanced at sound
sound design and that's by looking at
different plugins and seeing which
things carry over between them and then
experimenting the heck out of everything
and if you really want a advanced uh tip
is to go to your master and then just
spend time sound designing and just
messing around while you have an Edison
on your master and just click the record
button right here and then what I'll do
is I'll go back into my uh thing and
I'll just mess
around okay so like let's say you have
something like that and you're like I
don't know what you just did uh don't
worry so I have this right here I go
back to my uh playlist I can go to my
Edison and as I was recording that I can
actually click this button and it's
going to put exactly what we just
recorded into my
track so then maybe I want uh that to be
some like weird uh starting thing that I
have that's just like the beginning of a
track and then I stretch it a little bit
and I make it some background element
with Reverb and I click control L and I
add that and I put some like huge Reverb
on it and then
I I don't know do something like this
this and then I P P that
[Music]
down and then maybe I add some like
crazy grossy thing to it where it like
has some
[Music]
crazy maybe I C it
up
so as you can see you can do so much
from just messing around in your
synthesizer recording with Edison on
your master and it will record all crazy
things that happened in your synthesizer
so if you miss something you're like oh
that sounded really cool and you still
have it recorded in Edison and you can
use that later as samples uh for your
for your music obviously this was like a
really random weird example I probably
never use this in a in a song but it's
still interesting and you can still mess
around like that and I know I went
really fast with that I'm going to show
you guys more about sampling uh later
right right now we're just focused on
the south sign aspect so also I don't
know why that got applied to my master
very interesting okay so uh right here I
showed you guys pretty much I think
everything I want to do and I the reason
I did s design with vital is because I
think right now vital is probably one of
the best if not the best free
synthesizer in my opinion I've been
using it a ton is a huge I I love this I
love this Bing that's all all I'm going
to say uh Matrix okay so the Matrix is a
little bit more I don't I would say more
complicated to me than it is in serum
but uh it's still it's still cool uh I
don't really use the Matrix the whole
time I used it a ton in in serum I
haven't if I'm being completely honest I
just haven't found myself needing it yet
in vital but I know that is a huge what
is it called uh like a huge benefit if
you're doing some complex sound design
uh The Matrix is going to allow you to
more finely tune basically everything in
so like let's say you have all the UI
and it's kind of all spread out between
these knobs and it can be hard to see
like what's going on uh a matrix it kind
of just simplifies it down to like
basically inputs and outputs and very
like uh almost like a pro programmer
like language of how you use this uh I
don't use this too much I used to in
serum but with this I haven't spent the
time to learn it so I don't want to
teach you guys something that I don't
feel 100% Comfort Comfort confident in
but just know that uh there are good
resources for the Matrix and I don't use
that much and you don't need it to make
it good sounds all right with that said
uh the advanced again I have not really
uh messed with this at all so Matrix in
advance you don't even really need to
make really good sounds in vital uh
they're just extra things if you want to
learn them so there you go and just with
these Basics that I've taught you you
can pretty much make uh any sound that
you can imagine in your head like or any
any sound you can imagine in your head
any song that you any sound that you've
heard in another song unless it's some
super complicated dubstep sound like
you'll probably be able to re remake
that sound really easily just by knowing
knowing these few basic things so with
that being said I think that uh we're
going to go to the next chapter and
sound design
this is my sound design um part for this
chapter and let's go to the next
[Music]
one from here I also wanted to show you
guys uh more in-depth sound design that
I've actually used in real songs that I
have released on Spotify and I also
would like to go over some layering
techniques some automation techniques
and I just thought okay you going to be
way easier uh than just showing you guys
each of these things individually it's
just to go to a track I've already made
and then show you guys how I used it in
that particular track so right here I
have a track I've made and I actually
used um the uh Nitro pack that I added
for free to my sample pack uh on my on
my website so uh a lot of these uh
samples I'm using a lot of these presets
uh I used and you can get them too and
use the exact same ones that I used uh
in my samp pack on my website um also uh
i' go over the exactly how I made this
track completely in depth on my YouTube
channel where I also release uh
tutorials as well and that's just under
my name trist wox as uh just so you guys
can uh follow if you're interested so
without further Ado I'm going to play
what this sounds like and then we can go
over exactly how I sound designed some
of the things you can kind of get a
snippet of uh some more indepth sound
design for actual songs that I've used
it for and we can talk about what I
[Music]
did
so I released this as part of a
challenge to make a song in one hour to
see what I can make and this is actually
what I made so I would like to go over a
little bit of this because I think it's
really cool how you can see the advanced
production just condensed is like
quickly as possible so I'm I'm going to
be doing one more hour challenges and
I'm going to release the full things and
I think that this will also be a really
helpful way way for you guys to get to
see Advanced production action because
you'll see what things I think make a
song sound really good in the fastest
amount of times you kind of see the
whole process like compressed and then
over a 40 hour period of some like
really long Advanced course it would
basically be that process but just like
lengthened and added more time to it so
I could just fill out the song and do a
lot more stuff so with that being said
uh let's go and see the sound design of
the lead I think that that's really
leader base first let's
do let's do the base okay so I have the
Bas
[Music]
here so as you can see I actually the
pattern here is hugely important to the
way the sound sound design of the base
is made I have very short notes and then
I have uh ones that go up an octave that
help the lead or the base feel nice and
bouncy so this melody would be
completely ruined if I were to change
the way my base was and made it like
completely sustained for
[Music]
instance that actually sounds really
cool never mind I was wrong uh so
regardless uh let's go over uh how this
base works so this base basically has a
wave table that changes using this
envelope um let's see what that sounds
[Music]
like and that's literally all that's
going on with this oscillator uh in the
effect section I added a tiny bit of
course a lot of distortion I took out
the highs and I added a compressor so
really not too much going on so you
might be thinking how does this sound so
much better uh with um with the sound
with it being so simple because if you
copied exactly what I just did it would
not sound anything near what the final
sounds like and that's because of two
things one being that on my base I have
let me drag this so you guys can see it
uh I actually let's do this um just make
sure it's in view um I have uh different
things going on on the base effect rack
so I have a overdrive which is just
adding a tiny bit of distortion I have
an EQ which is affecting the way the
balance of the sound is I have a sound
cizer which uh yeah you can make fun of
me now I love using sound cizer I don't
know why it makes it sound good and I
know a lot of people say it's terrible
for your songs but I digress it sounds
good um so that's it that's all I added
and it just really beefs up the sound uh
so that's really all that's going on
with the base um I know it sounds cool
but there's not too much going on I just
had a little bit Distortion a little bit
compression EQ here and there and then
just try to keep it simple and I mean
the end result I think it sounds pretty
good uh I just added a couple other
presets here as you can see and one of
them was a one octave up just to add a
little bit more a mid-base field to the
[Music]
sound so I have actually three
oscillators you can almost think of it
as layering three separate bases which
is part of sound design is layering so
uh this you could think of this uh
preset as having three different layers
if if you will
[Music]
and then I just uh changeed the levels
of this to get the desired sound I want
if I were to change this it could change
dramatically
[Music]
so you can see just just by changing
those around it can really affect the
the sound uh next I have the lead sound
[Music]
now the the reason that this one sounds
so quiet is because of the different
automations when everything's when all
the automations are turned on this lead
is a lot louder but we can still listen
to
it so look at how many times I play the
same note in a row one two three three
I'm going to count that four even though
there's slide five six yeah six times so
six times in a row I get away with
playing the exact same note so your
Melodies do not have to go up and down
like crazy to create a really uh cool
melody in my opinion uh you don't need
to make them super complicated just make
it easier for the ear to follow and
catchy and this works because I have a
cool Basse pattern going and then this
assist I play the same lead and with the
drums it just kind of hits at the same
time so it's like oh what's going to
happen because you hear like let me just
show you so like like three times you
hear it hit and you're like waiting for
something to happen it's like all right
let's let's just turn on everything
here it's like almost like you think it
might you think the melody might start
then the second time but then nothing
happens the third time nothing happens
and then
same I'm like just pushing your
expectation just a little bit further
and you're like uh and then and then
it's cool because I removed all the
drums here and then it they came back in
so you can see how like my entire
production is revolving around like I I
just made a heart uh Revol Ving around
what I think would be essentially like
cool like I'm like okay well if I'm
playing the same three notes right here
I'll remove all the drums to build up
like anticipation for when my melody
does start um if I was just a music
producer and I wasn't an artist I would
just be
like like I I would never think uh I
would never think of that I I might just
put the drums all the way across because
that's like a normal thing to do and it
might just sound like pretty
boring it doesn't have the same feel uh
in my opinion so
that's that's one thing is that like
you're influencing your decisions and
your production techniques based off of
what idea you have and so that's the key
thing to being an artist is that you're
actually the process of music production
changes based off of what you're trying
to accomplish and so if you don't have
that uh if you don't have that like okay
so when you start off you might not have
an exact idea for what you want to make
you just start making something but then
an idea that you kind of realize that
there was a reason behind all the
actions that you were doing and all the
choices you were making and you can if
if you can kind of like hold on to that
then you can like make the whole song
around that idea it's I know this is
sounds so complicated but it's really
just like an experience that you have to
have making music and I have shared this
experience with so many different people
who make music they know exactly what
I'm talking about there's something that
you can kind of like feel and you're
like yeah this is the direction I need
to go and then once you can kind of hold
on to that and like make the whole song
around it that's really when you're uh
making doing like doing art it's not
just like uh the difference is that if
you're just kind of making music and
doing stuff and you're not feeling
anything and there's no idea that's like
kind of pulling you to to make certain
production decisions then I don't think
that you're really making music if that
makes sense like there's a there's a a
huge difference between those two uh and
I know I've already mentioned this like
four times but I just really want to
drive it home that point because it's so
important uh but anyways I digress again
so let's listen to some of the cooler
things I did with my drums here so I
showed you oh wait I didn't show you my
lead s design my bad guys okay so uh
lead is not too complicated I just have
uh it's it's almost the same as my base
I think I took my Basse preset and
literally just pitched it up I'm not
even kidding and then I think I changed
the wave table that was it uh so this is
actually the same as my base so I
literally did the exact same thing I
might have just changed the envelope a
little bit and that was the only
difference I made and then for the
second lead I just changed it so the a
part of My Melody has has one has one
sound as you can hear this is the
a so this is like the a part of my
melody and this is the B part with a
different sound
and again we can distinguish the A and
the B parts of My Melody based off of
the Rhythm that they're playing so
technically this is like a b c c okay
and the A and the B are kind of using
the same the same melody or the same
sound okay to introduce the the next
part and so I actually I kind of belabor
the point of my of My Melody by changing
the instrument when it changes the
Rhythm and changes uh Melodies is I I
want to kind of emphasize that change by
changing the sound so if I use the same
sound the whole way through I feel like
this would be incredibly boring so like
I can I can show you what that sound
like it would sound like
[Music]
this so it's sound like
this I mean it's still cool I not even
going to lie it is kind of cool but it's
just not the
same it it sounds cooler when it changes
here I I also noticed that it also
sounded cooler when I changed it because
I forgot that my automations changed and
at the end of the automation it actually
shifted the sound entirely so this
actually would have worked anyways and
got the same thing I just did it
differently here anyways uh you probably
are wondering about this sound right
[Music]
here and if you were just watching my
sound design section you would have saw
exactly how I did this technique and if
you are really clever you might have
actually known how I made this sound so
if I go into my piano roll and open up
fidal you can see that I actually have
this aane all the way up I don't know
why it's so short that doesn't really
matter though uh and I have an LFO which
has my frequency on seconds so it does
that exact that that thing I was talking
about where it goes like and then it
like lengthens out you saw me messing
around with
that it's doing that with vital so hold
on let me go to attached
view sorry I know this is like so messy
here I'm trying to get it organized so
you guys can see what's going on uh
let's just close it thing and then
reopen it back
up okay okay let's
go
[Music]
here so you see you see what's changing
down in this LFO that's that's what's
going on and I'm automating that uh LFO
with a automation here you can see I'm
the LFO frequency see going down
here so as it goes down it increases in
seconds so that is what I'm doing so I
just want to show you a real life
example of me automating a knob in vital
in my song to make an effect that I was
trying to get uh anyways okay so I'm
going to take this off to attach because
I can't say uh let's go to my drums and
now I I showed you guys the lead and the
bases it's so simple I literally just
had one uh synth for each and then I
just processed the the lead and the lead
processing was so so simple what I did
was I basically actually used my my base
what's it called my base
uh uh insert as a bus for my lead in my
base and you might be going like what in
the world you put your lead into your
base I did and it and it kind of works
so I'm not even going to lie I think the
reason it works is because the
compression of the lead and the base go
together before it gets recompressed on
the master and that's why it's so like
uh kind of loud and it just works so for
my lead preset I literally just have
fresh air which uh kind of increases the
highing gives it a little bit more
crispiness um I have Crush automations
which are just bit crush and those turn
on and off throughout the song and kind
of highlight different parts of the
melody with bit crush and I have another
KZ bit Crush all these are free plugins
by the way delay very cool I don't think
I ended up using this but it is a very
cool plugin and then I just cut out some
of the lows so it left some room for the
base and then I boost to the highs again
so that's what I did and then on my lead
I also always make sure to add white
noise so the reason I do this is because
it fills up all that highend so I pitch
the White Noise up to 48 uh and then I
just
have it hit on it depends on how you
want it but I kind of automate it so
that the white noise gives it more
crispy like Snap because if I take this
out and play
it see how lame that sounds but then
when I add White
Noise has so much more energy it's like
it's like not even comparable so if
you're not using white noise you're
really shooting yourself in the foot is
terms of like energy for these type of
music uh and obviously you may not be
making this type of music but still
white noise is is huge so let's play the
drums and just listen what the
[Music]
sound first of all I am complimenting my
kick drum by having uh these claps and
ride
so and then this is an example of just
percussion uh that I added in I'm like
oh it sound cool and this is literally
me this is the process of advanced
production I'm going here and going oh
but happened if I took this this symbol
and like Shunk it down like to a fourth
of its side just played it over and over
and over again right here it's
like and then I increase the volume of
these very slowly so it's was like and
then that's literally what I'm doing I'm
just like sitting here like minutely
changing these things to make something
that sounds cool that's like that's
Advanced production a beginner they just
would like pull a sample and this is
nothing wrong with this I do this all
the time sometimes it's actually better
like you'll see over in the beginning of
my song I did I just literally pulled
the seatics hip-hop drum Loop because I
was like oh this sounds good and and
that's fine but I also know how to make
drum Loops too it's not like I don't
know what I'm doing like I just did it
because it sounded good and that's the
end quality that I wanted but I I'm also
capable and this is I think the thing
you don't want to be using tools that
take away from the skill that you don't
have so you should be able to do pretty
much everything but on your own and then
just use the tools as complimentary
things that aren't holding up your
production but are like helping you do
things that you already know how to do
but just uh saving you time or uh
improving your creative work so yeah
whoops uh so I also took the kick and
reversed it so it kind of like sucks it
back in the kick right here you hear
that going
if so that just keeps it interesting
just like little tidbits here and there
and these this is just the type type of
stuff that happens when you're like
working for long times on tracks I mean
this one obviously was an hour so I
didn't have a ton of time but uh it was
uh quite fun to add a all of stuff in so
I'm trying to think what else I can show
you guys so I uh added a obviously
automations here and there to exemplify
different parts of the melody the A and
B Parts uh by automating different
aspects of the of the sound and I also
have reeverb automations that go in
between the notes so that uh the Reverb
plays when there's no note playing so it
kind of fills that space a little bit
and then I always make sure that I have
a little bit of a background noise going
in the background so that you can uh it
fills up those empty gaps and doesn't
make the song sound so dry so like if I
take this
[Music]
out you can see the difference is
absolutely massive so
and there was other parts I took out so
some things I mute because I'm like I I
didn't like the way that turned out so
like I I guess I had this I don't know
what this
[Music]
was so I said okay I don't like that so
I took it out so you can mute ideas
overtime too and some things that don't
fit and that's perfectly fine so that's
just part of the process um I don't know
how much more I have to show you guys I
guess other than maybe this 808 was like
really cool uh it sounded pretty
interesting so like if I go to the
beginning of the track
here
[Music]
so I literally just took the same base
and
it's just automated different things to
make it fit uh it's just like your
standard 808 sound I thought it I
thought it was really cool and I kind of
reuse things to make uh make it go
faster so I reuse this base uh from the
drop as my 808 in this part of the
hip-hop song uh so that's kind of what I
did um I'm trying to think what else to
show you guys I use delay to have a cool
intro effect here so that's why it
sounds like it's repeating itself over
and
over
you hear that like let me turn it off
and you'll you'll hear the difference in
like what goes on when I turn that
off okay let's play
[Music]
now here there's like no repeating and
then like let me turn the this delay
back on you'll see the the effect I had
I think it was huge I think that this
really
[Music]
made
see how cool that is I I love that delay
effect I a friend show it to me and I've
been using it like ever since um I have
this really cool thing I do in the in
the beginning of all my songs with
convolver so if you want to steal my
signature artist thing that I do go for
it uh so basically this is what it
sounds
like I have a convolver on the
master and right here what this does is
it basically I put the preset on
[Music]
B and then I automated it from 100% to
zero and
and if I turn like the pink noise all
the way up in any part of the song
you'll hear what it
does it like just washes everything out
it sounds so cool and so epic I love
like doing that to like kind of
introduce a new part of the song so uh I
showed you guys about layering I showed
you guys about layering different sounds
uh the one thing I didn't describe to
you guys is that uh each sound that I
picked in this particular track I had a
specific Place board so I picked the
three different um oscillators in my
base because I wanted a mid base I
wanted a sign subbase and I wanted a
another low base so that's why I picked
three different sways and they're all
serving a different purpose then I
picked my lead and I picked it and I'm
like okay the lead will go in the higher
uh range so that's why I cut the low or
the highs out of the base so that the
highs for my lead would fit there and
you can kind of see my my head working
like I'm like okay I don't want the base
to have a ton of highs because I know
the lead is going to have a lot of highs
and so I'm sound designing and doing my
sound selection based off of the needs
of my track so I'm not just adding a ton
of sounds throwing sounds at the wall
until something sticks what I'm doing is
I'm selectively and subconsciously
picking sounds that fit the the ENT the
entire hole I did the hard thing again
uh to fit the entire hole the way that
I'm looking to do so that's how you
should be picking out sounds it's uh
pick out sounds like you're putting
stuff in your fridge from the grocery
store you have like you wouldn't just
Chuck everything in the in the fridge
you have to like methodically go okay I
have room for this here this here I need
something that's going to fit here so
I'll put something here and you're like
methodically packing everything packing
is also a great example there's so many
different examples I can use for mixing
it's like packing it's like you have a
ton of clothes that you need to fit for
your trip and you're packing them in
certain spots and if you just chuck all
your clothes in there there's a very low
likelihood that it's going to fit
together so if your mix sucks it's
probably because you're throwing a bunch
of random stuff in your suitcase and
you're not actually deciding okay do I
actually need to bring this is this
useful nope going to check that out
because that's just a random Pizza
t-shirt that I don't need so there's
just like random things that you put in
there it's probably not going to sound
very good so just be very what is the
word like intentional um and and uh
it'll become subconscious over time of
what sounds you're putting in there but
basically try to fill everything up so
everything has its particular spot and
nothing's fighting for space amongst
each other and you won't need to have a
million eqs eqing everything because the
sounds that you pick will just fit so
well together that they don't need
anything else um last thing I guess I
could go over uh within this track uh
that will show some more advanced
production techniques is the fact that I
used um my master I literally I showed
you the convolution thing I added an OT
this is hilarious I have no idea why
this OT is on my master but it sounded
really good for this song I don't
normally endorse this I think that
putting this OT on your master it
probably is going to make mess up a lot
of stuff for some reason it just sounds
good and I listen to my mix and mono too
and I think it's okay so uh sometimes
the sck stuff works but I wouldn't
recommend it and sometimes it can get
you in hot water so I think I
accidentally added this and I just kept
it so sometimes that happens um happy
accidents Bob R Us uh so with my fruity
balance I usually have a fruity balance
to just turn down everything and then I
Master it uh this for some reason I
didn't uh I'll show you a different
example that this EQ barely boosting
barely uh cutting just very basic stuff
here um if you guys can't see my master
chain I'm sorry I realized that is
probably out of key okay there we go now
it's now it's better um so I have my uh
parametric EQ just barely cutting barely
doing anything make sure to turn the
linear button on if this is your master
EQ because you uh don't want to create
phasing issues or any different issues
like that um fresh air I do this just to
boost the highs of the entire track it
fantastic uh this is a Frank pull free
plugin it's called inflator it's based
off of the Oxford inflator uh again it's
an upwards compressor and I use this on
my track to kind of bring up the low
points and just make it sound more full
um then I added a midside EQ so I could
dynamically boost the mono subbase and I
could cut the wide base on my track and
boost the the side highs so the width of
a track in the mono of a track I have
separated in two different eqs that are
both on linear mode and then I boost uh
the EQ on the side in the side of my
headphones I boost the highs in the
sides and I cut the the base in the
sides the low subbase and then in the
mono frequencies I boost this sub and I
don't really do anything with the with
the rest of the mix and if you want this
uh I have it also in my sample pack but
it's so easy to make and I would feel
if I didn't just show you uh
just how to make it yourself so this is
what it is it's just this this is what
the midside splitter looks like you just
open up Patcher put this here and then
you just uh take one of the outputs put
it to an and the other output to another
EQ and then you drag it back to FL
Studio like so and then that will give
you a midside EQ which is probably one
of the
most nerdy but like cool things to do is
to midside EQ everything and uh
dynamically control the way your sound
sounds with different uh and your mono
and wide I I do I love doing that it's
one of my favorite mixing techniques and
it honestly will level up your
Productions like from here to here if
you just start using midside EQ uh in my
opinion uh soft Clipper this is just my
limiter cuz I didn't pay for anything so
this is my free limiter is it just a
soft Clipper so just goes to show I used
to use pro2 I loved it and then I'm my
computer crossed I lost everything and
now I'm back to soft Clipper so there
there you have it uh two last things I
can show you is on my the C the for
stands for I don't know what it stands
for so I'm not going to make it up uh
you click that it's not your master and
I put a span on here and this just helps
me see what's going on in my track
dynamically with my
EQ and this is pretty much the best like
like as terms of a mix like if you're
just like looking at that
like look at this it's like it's
beautiful like this is the what you are
aiming for you like you have the the
base and then it lowers off in the muddy
region and then the mids aren't
overtaking the entire track but then the
highs are boosted up again to the human
ear this sounds really good this sounds
really good uh this is kind of what
you're looking for if you have too much
going on in here gets out a little bit
muddy if you have too much going in here
it might take away uh the balance of the
track it might take away from the
dynamic of it if you have a lot going on
in here you're going to have a lot of
energy in your track if you have a lot
going in here it's going to it's going
to it's going to hit it's going to hit
hard okay in the in the cars so if you
want to hear what it sounds like in your
car without going to your car uh Frank
pole has another amazing plugin called
uh Inspector Gadget uh no it's not
called Inspector Gadget it's called
inspector 2 and you can click this on
and it'll simulate different
[Music]
environments so I gu simulates like a
really bad speaker I don't know what
that
[Music]
is outside the club is just this is all
you hear is just low
it's your side
mix invert the polarity swap the sides
and just hear the offset left and right
solo super great I love this and then I
just turned it off uh and then yeah so
that's my master chain I showed you my
mix chains I showed you how I layer I
showed you how I do my effects I showed
you how how to do my automations I show
you how to do rhythms with drums sorry
for talking so much um and I showed you
how it's okay to use samples and Loops
but it's also good to make your own and
that you shouldn't use it as crutches
but it's using samples a completely
legitimate way of producing um what else
to talk about I guess Arrangement uh so
arrangement I have I try to have some
rhythmic element in every part of my
track except for the the com the first
like eight bars sometimes I'll have it
very washed out and you're like oh
what's going on it sounds cool and then
it like goes straight into like the the
Bas
in go straight into this
[Music]
part
so that's something I'll do um what else
I have the buildup here obviously this
is a certain style of music so you're
thinking like okay this is EDM uh so or
electronic dance music particular this
would be Basse house maybe future house
uh is um that's kind of the what your
what genre it would fit in um if you
don't make this type of music that's
fine your Arrangements is going to just
look different uh but these producing
techniques are Universal and where you
can take these techniques I've taught
you to any genre I've made hip-hop
before I've made pop rock all kinds of
different
in learning EDM is I think the single
greatest asset you can do to improve
your production in all areas because
electronic music production teaches you
every area of music production whereas
if I just do instrumentals I'm not going
to learn a lot of flu because I don't
need to with electronic music production
there's so many different techniques
that so many people use that it just you
can learn so much and then and then
reapply it to certain specific genres so
if you make hip-hop and you just
practice your electronic music
production I think that it will really
help you with hip-hop uh this is
something that I learned is that I
people who I make hip-hop for they're
like wow these songs are like really
interesting I haven't heard something
like this it's because I'm not a hip-hop
producer I'm a EDM producer who tried to
make hip-hop by listening to some things
and so my takes on things and my Beats
and stuff that I make gets out a lot
more interesting and not like copy paste
what other hip-hop producers do because
of just you come from a different place
so experiment by making lots of
different genres and will actually
improve the overall quality of all your
music across the board uh that's one
thing that you can take from this so uh
I hope this was help I just went through
this part uh now we're going to go to
the next part of the tutorial and I'll
see you
there in this chapter I'm going to show
you uh some other tips that have to do
with Melodies harmonies and just overall
uh instrumentation and layering so right
here I have what's called a layer if you
go to plus uh you can add in a layer I
forgot I already forgot where it was uh
there it is right there so you can add
in a layer and what that will do is it
allow you to play two instruments at the
same time on your keyboard so I added
one Labs piano
fre sampler by the way lives are
fantastic and then I added another
preset
here but when I click my layer it plays
both at the same
time which is really cool so the way I
did this is that I selected all of these
at the same time with my layer open and
you click set children and then this uh
becomes a parent uh congratulations he's
the father so uh we're going to go to
the piano roll and we have this layer
right here and when I whenever I place a
note it's going to play both of these
instruments at the same
time so you can hear the piano at the
same time so now I'm going to go through
some of the uh some of the midi that I
have from my sample pack uh again my
sample Pack's on my website if you're
interested and uh and right here I'm
just going to use some of the mini as an
example of different ways you can make
Melodies and uh just understand uh
Melody and Harmony making so let's just
start with the first one I have no idea
what this sounds
like whoa so fast all right let's slow
this down to like 110
[Music]
Maybe
so as you can see uh let's just uh
simplify this down so uh I have this one
Baseline
going and this is just a normal Baseline
like this is pretty much as simple as it
gets and then on top of this I just
added uh another uh note the compliment
it another Harmony
there two different
[Music]
notes and you see right here that I have
an a b a b Melody why is that because
this a parts match together and then the
rhythm of these B Parts match together
because these two notes at the end are
matching so I have a b a b okay and then
with that Melody I added another on top
of
there
and then this uh has its own pattern to
it um which somehow works in the in the
process of the whole even though that
they're actually kind of all different
but I still say it's a a b anyways um
but it's a little bit more complex uh
basically I just kind of this is just
trial and eror just like placing okay I
have this pattern or idea or Motion in
my head what am I trying to get out on
[Music]
here like I just kind of had this idea
I'm like okay uh let's uh like here's a
better example I want to start from
scratch I'll just make ail you guys can
kind of see what I'm
doing so it's
like I I can't sing but you get the
[Music]
idea
this something like you know you can
make all kinds of different Melodies and
I just there's like pretty much like an
infinite array of different Melodies
that could be played on top of this but
a lot of it comes from uh just kind of
experience I guess is the best way to
put it uh I made lots of bad Melodies
and so by making lots of bad Melodies
over and over again you can kind of see
um I just want to show you a lot of
Melody so you can kind of see the
patterns between them and hopefully get
a better sense of like what uh you can
be looking at when you're trying to make
good Mel so let's skip this one I want
to make okay let's see what this
is
so again I have this uh interesting
thing so these are basically just chords
and then I have it playing almost like
an art Melody so I can have I could have
had this like
[Music]
this like
this this was a completely valid and
thing I could have
[Music]
done
but it sounds interesting when I have it
playing like an
art so just experiment with maybe it
sounds better if your chords are playing
more of an art Melody uh maybe that
leads into the melody overall as a whole
um so that's another thing that you
could uh try to experiment with um let's
keep going and see what other Melodies I
have here that's a little complicated to
skip
[Music]
that
so as you can see here I have a very
simple uh like cor progression because
it just it does it's not like a
complicated Rhythm you know it's just
playing like these four bars and it's
just if I delete everything else but
selected you can hear how simple this is
so if I
select um int selection and then just
[Music]
delete this a very simple core
progression and then this melody on top
of it is what gives it all the depth
that it has and um I think that doing
that is by having a solid if you build a
solid Baseline you can build a solid
core progression on top of that and you
can make a solid Melody on top of that
or you can go the reverse Direction I
tend to find that either by building a
strong base you can it can inspire a
melody or if you have a strong Melody it
can Inspire everything below it so you
know what why don't we just try making a
corporation maybe that that'll help you
guys so uh something that you could do
is just start with a Basse so I'll do it
both ways I'll start with the melody one
time and I'll start with a base another
so let's just copy
[Music]
this this is very mysterious very
interesting so so what if I do something
[Music]
like so I'm going to add a middle notes
to
[Music]
these
this is kind of interesting I'm trying
to figure out exactly how to how to pars
it here then you can take these middle
notes and you can go up and active I'm
not sure how I'm feeling about this
Corporation so
[Music]
far
I wonder what this sounds
[Music]
like it's interesting um it's definitely
I guess I don't know what the word is
I'm not 100% feeling it yet so what I
might do is I might take uh these notes
and just uh put them up an
[Music]
octave
as as you can see for me it's a lot of
trial on there seeing what sounds good
not like good right off the
bat that doesn't sound very good
[Music]
either
somehow every single one of these notes
sounds bad I like that I don't like that
chord so you can see like sometimes like
Melodies they they don't come too easily
so sometimes like starting the Baseline
didn't really work that time so like I'm
going to try a
melody
[Music]
it's also difficult and I notic this uh
from recording other times as well is
that uh long periods of silence for me
uh happen because I'm thinking and I'm
also trying to produce and teaching and
producing are like two different sides
of my brain so like I almost cannot do
it at the same time and switching
between them as you can see is a very
difficult for me and also makes it
really hard to make Melodies and a lot
of times I'll spend even longer making
really bad Melodies until something good
comes up uh so it just goes to show that
not every time you open up the pan roll
you're going to make something awesome
and sometimes you could use a different
source of inspiration so for that reason
why don't I try finding a sample and
maybe that can uh help me come up with a
cool melody or something that could help
ins Spark some inspiration so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to open up adsr
sample manager and this is so awesome
because if you download free sample
packs or buy sample packs what happens
is is that they can all be stored in
adsr Sample manager and then I can
search up different types of samples and
it will sort them for me automatically
and I can cool very quickly find
something I'm looking for so I'm going
to look up for a cool drum sample uh
sample and then just scroll and then I
only want Loops so I'm going to click
off of that
Arrow
okay so 110 that sounded really cool I'm
going to use this metal Rhythm and I'm
going to turn it down in octave just to
see what it sounds
like that's really cool okay so I'm
going to go back here and I'm going to
search up instead of drums I'm going to
find some type of weird guitar Loop
Maybe and Just scroll down
that's really
interesting okay so now we have
this okay this is really cool so now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
take this sample and I'm actually going
to put it uh why so what uh I'm going to
teach you guys how to use the sampler
and I'm going to teach you guys how to
make Melodies so I'll just do both at
the same time kill two BRS with one
stone uh so except there will be no
death in making this video okay so uh
when I open up the sample here is I just
double click on any sample and I can
change different uh thing things and
qualities about it so right there I
turned down the pitch of the sample down
an octave uh there's also reverse I
could reverse the
[Music]
sample
that's also kind of cool uh you can do
all sorts of things I can change how how
long it takes before the sample goes in
I can change how long it takes till the
sample goes out I can cross fade it uh
which is really complicated but really
cool um if I click not this wrench tool
but if I click the other tool it lets me
boost the volume of that I can clip I
can clip it I do that a lot for drums
and make it sound really cool um you can
also add stereo delay which is going to
make it sound really wide but it is
going to mess up the stereo image
slightly
[Music]
all the St image is fine right now so
I'll leave you that with the stereo
widened and then I'll control L with
this guitar as well I'm going to add a
CH to this guitar because I feel like
that would sound really cool so I'm just
add a vintage chorus turn that
[Music]
down I'm going to cut out the lows out
of
[Music]
the and then this is just a a loop so I
still need to add like drums so what I'm
going to do is I'm going to go to uh my
own sample pack this is not the one I'm
selling but this is just the one I've
built over time so I'm going to just
find some kind of cool clap here it's
like a hip-hop
clap
that's fine we'll just use this one so
we
have oh I want it I want it fast just
like
[Music]
this
and then I need a high hat so I need the
high hat to kind of just play over and
over
again a very fast I had like yeah
perfect just something like this and
then I'm going to go to my pain tool and
just paint
across I'm going to put contr l and then
I'm going to add pancake onto it and
what pancake does is it's funny because
I had pancakes R this morning uh
pancakes is pancakes pancake 2 is going
to change the St image to go left and
right so it'll make it more interesting
for our high house you hear going back
and
[Music]
forth and then you know why don't we add
a crazy Reverb on this and then have it
uh just Decay over time it just gets uh
turned down over time so we we'll just
turn that uh Decay or turn the Reverb
off then create an automation like this
and then have it start all the way at
the top and then lower over
[Music]
time and then we could have it go like a
crazy 808 just hit really hard and then
we could have a kick uh let's make a
kick and clap a combo here that's
perfect just use that kick so have it
kind of go
[Music]
late just the easiest drum Loop of all
time and then just copy and paste that
over and over again so we'll just select
uh the drums that we have here highlight
them uh select that part of the song and
only the drums and control bbbbb and
then it's going to put that exactly over
and over again for us and then to make
it really interesting let's zoom in here
copy this drum again paste it click make
unique as sample and then go here and
then reverse it and then we can just uh
not stretch it but we can click off a
stretch then we can turn this down oh my
goodness I can't click turn this down
like that like so and then that will
make it so that it kind of
slides uh and then we'll just take that
out and then make it a little bit
[Music]
longer
and then we'll add a base here so now we
need to add an 808 so this 808 uh we
want it to H hard so we are going to put
an 808 Loop here uh and I'm going to go
to vital and I'm going to go to whatever
808 sample I
have and I'm just going to put contr l
and then I'm going to go and find the
exact so I save all my presets and I
save all of my effects for those presets
so I have file save mixer track state as
so if I make any changes to this mixer I
add things I like at the end of it I can
go on this mixer right click go to file
save as and I can save and type in the
name that I want that mixer preset to be
and I can go to my um the the sound
that's going to that mixer and then go
up here to the file go save preset as
and then I click that and I name it the
exact same thing so that I can open up
my sound and I can open up my mixture
preset for that sound every time I want
it so then I have uh I can save my work
from other songs and put them in in over
time so so I'm never like losing my work
uh and it helps you be a better producer
over time because then you can have your
work carry over you know so that's
pretty cool uh let's make an 88
[Music]
preset I don't really like the state
away so we're going to change
it it's just too I don't know it's not
really working for me so let's find
something
else let's see did I make another
one maybe I don't have
[Music]
one see if I can make something quick
here
[Music]
we'll just copy paste this and then
change the thing it
[Music]
hits
it's not really fitting for me
[Music]
I'm not really deing the 808 pattern
right here at all I think it's not it's
because I don't like uh the patch either
so I'm going to change the flex I'm just
going to go to premade 808 so I don't
take forever on making something but as
you can see lots of ideas and lots of
things that you try are not going to
work first try and the point is not to
try something it doesn't work and then
quit because that's what a beginner
producer does uh an advanced producer
Tres something it doesn't work owns up
to the fact that it didn't work and try
something else again um and I made
plenty of hip-hop songs before but not
every single one turns out the way I
wanted to and not every idea turns out
the same so what I'm going to do is I'm
just going to find a different thing and
see if I can make it
[Music]
work
first of all it's because this is out of
key so I need to fix that and then I can
also fix it a little bit by just maybe
clipping it here
[Music]
instead
m
[Music]
so it's
not I mean yeah this happens this is my
like favorite song in the entire world
um I wish I could have made something
more interesting here I had an idea and
I kind of lost it already because it's
kind of taking me too long uh which
happen so I might need to come up with a
different new idea again I think that
part of the issue with uh trying to show
Advanced production live for me is uh
that the part of my brain that explains
and the part of my brain that produces
two different parts and sometimes it
takes me 5 minutes to make something
really cool sometimes it makes me it
takes me 2 hours and obviously I don't
have that kind of like I don't have the
luck that every single idea I come up
with that hopefully while I'm making the
tutorial live that it's going to be good
but um that's just the way it is
sometimes so uh hopefully by me not
being able to make something cool you
guys could to learn something too and
that it's encouraging that not every
time that you sit down at the computer
you're going to make something but I
forgot what saying it was but it's uh
that sometimes that it's inevitable that
you're going to make something something
good you just have to sit through the
production times of making bad things
over and over again to get them out of
the way until the good thing comes along
so hopefully that's encouraging for you
is that every time that you sit the
computer don't expect to make something
good but rather just go hey if I make
something bad that's one less bad thing
I have until I make something good so
just think just change your mind mindset
a little bit differently and then
hopefully that will encourage you to
make better things so uh I showed you
guys about the sampler and different
things that you can do in the sampler uh
one thing that I really like to do also
is is go to stretch Pro and then change
this and this just format shifts it so
you can have all kinds of really cool
stuff
[Music]
here I still really like this beginning
part it's really chill uh it's really
cool so um that's just uh just another
example just the format shifting I love
doing that to vocals sounds really cool
and then um putting this on stretch Pro
also if I change this an octave down it
won't change
the
but if I uh put this just on stretch
listen into it
now with stretch Pro it like tries to
retain the same format it's
[Music]
interesting it it's quite interesting so
I really like using the format shift the
stretch Pro whenever they added that
huge huge I love that update so much so
that's just something cool uh also you
can change the octave by uh right
clicking on these notes this will change
it so
[Music]
just another way for you to change the
picture if you need to go a little bit
further in pitch um anyways so I showed
you guys how to use the sampler I showed
you guys uh different ways that you can
use samples in your Productions uh and I
also showed you guys uh a little bit
about making Melodies uh the funny thing
was is that uh pretty much all the
Melodies I made today were not good and
then all the samples I tried using in
production also weren't good but I did
like this um this one percussion Loop
here editing that to make it fit with
this beginning part that at least was
kind of interesting um so hopefully you
guys got to saw a little bit of that U
maybe I could pull up another production
and then show you guys a different
example of something that I did turn out
well and then we'll go with that right
now all right so I found a project that
I worked on and this was something I
made a little while ago and this shows a
better example of how you can use
samples and Melodies uh more effectively
and just making a very simple production
so this was just a very basic idea I
made so this was a sample I made
[Music]
and that come from and that came from
this and I love that was a weird ending
uh I love uh using these samples just as
quick idea starters for me um they
really help me when I making music but
this is something uh that I made uh it
just has a few different patterns so
this is one of
them so you see I have multiple layers
going on at the same time so I have
let's just play the bass in this
one
so you see I have a call it's kind of
like asking a
question you can almost see that this
this first part right here is just
asking a
question and then this is an
answer this ask the same question
again but with a different base so it's
like almost like a different I don't
even know and then a different
answer and then it plays the same again
goes over
again and then add
the same thing
again with a different base pattern and
then finishes off by the kind of
completing the whole
thing and then it repeats the whole
thing and then I have a different
completely different pattern going in
the background
this so as you can see I have a counter
Melody here I have my main Melody here
and I have my 808 base just playing a
very simple Melody here and when all
these things combine I with the melody
and the counter Melody and the Basse you
have a full uh more complete track and
then what I did was I actually exported
that Melody out and then messed with it
around by pitching it down and changing
the way it was formed and stuff and then
added tons of effects to it
[Music]
so you see add these kind of
effects I could have made it even more
interesting by adding like a
[Music]
chorus done all kinds of stuff I could
have done like update
[Music]
presser try
that that might be a little bit too much
but you know what there's like different
things you can try here so uh try
sampling your own Melodies so like make
melodies a sample out of it by going up
here right clicking going to consolidate
track and then from track start or song
Start whichever one you'd like and then
what that's going to do is is going to
consolidate that into a meel uh into a
sample and then you can use that sample
to either develop your own sample packs
or to make your own tracks and that's
what I mostly use it for so I hopefully
this was a better example than me uh
failing multiple times on how to make uh
Melodies and how to uh make just beats
and just like um uh how to use samples
uh in your Productions but hopefully
this was a uh a good um a better example
of what can happen so uh and notice that
I made this probably when I wasn't
recording and when I was just kind of
like oh I have this idea in my head and
then it just kind of happen so um those
are two different ways that you can
produce and so hopefully that was more
helpful for you
[Music]
uh you may have been wondering why it
took me so long to release this course
and I want to tell you I have tried
recording this course so many times and
just to prove it I'm actually going to
show you one of the versions of this
course and never got released it was me
making a 1hour challenge and then that
1hour challenge I was going to take and
then collab with my friend who's going
to record vocals his guitar we're going
to record all everything and then we're
going to finish that song and then I was
going to analyze the collab edit that we
did together as the final uh thing for
the for the full Advanced uh uh tutorial
so I thought hey why not just add that
onto the tutorial I've already gotten
finished so I did so I'm added after
this you're going to see a another 1our
section of me making a 1 hour challenge
just to show you what the advanced uh
production technique looks like when
it's condensed into a shorter time frame
and I you can tell in that video I was
really not feeling it I was like I I
don't know if this is going to turn into
anything I was just I was nervous I
wasn't sure I record the video so many
times I was like it's probably just be
another take I'm not going to use but I
am going to use it and you know what I'm
going to show you what the final track
between uh me and blender base turned
out like and it's not even close to
finished which is sad but hey it happens
uh and the project file that I have is
uh kind of I'm going to try to find it
I'm going to try to reop it and then
I'll analyze that after I show you the 1
hour challenge and then I'll try to do
that as well just to kind of finish out
on a strong note so without further Ado
uh I'm just going to play this uh
version of the song and then uh I will
show you the 1 hour challenge and from
there I will go into the project for
this one hour challenge that is
corrupted and some of it doesn't work
but I still want to show you at least
what we got done um so I'll play this
and then you can see the one hour
challenge and see how it cut to this
point all
right
[Music]
he
in the front seat listening to the car
and you
H the horiz behind me looking at the
dashboard fast FL and driving front SE
listen to the G and
you in Rise behind me looking at the
dashboard fast forward
driv
[Music]
to
oh
[Music]
a
anyways so that is super crazy uh super
interesting a lot of it is like stuff
I've never made before he's never made
before it's just like this crazy idea is
Just Happening uh a lot of it is like
really experimental is the word I'd use
it's not like something you listen to on
the radio it's kind of like what is this
like I've never heard anything like this
but it's cool it's it's fun to make
stuff like this um anyways uh so now
here's the one hour challenge and when
you come back from this and see what I
worked on for an hour you can see what
uh blend base uh helps collab on so
let's let's check it
out
okay okay so my first attempt I forgot
to hit the timer so I'm gonna have to
restart so this is going to be attempt
two so let me repare my
notepad this is attempt two and this
time I'm actually going to start the
timer let's just open up a new thing of
FL
fresh and then we're just going to
collapse everything in the
browser all
right now I'm just going to hit the
timer and we are going to go so let's
try this again attempt two this time I
hit the timer so I'm actually doing the
challenge that's unfortunate uh okay so
I'm going to start off last time we
started off with the drums and it's kind
of sounded interesting but this time I
want to start off with a piano so we're
going to do a little bit
different
um let's see I want to pick something
cool like I want to make something
that's
like like house drums but like
acoustic so I want to try something
interesting
basically go here let me turn my
notifications off on my phone so
Focus uh can Volver I highly recommend I
actually when I would produce I put my
phone in a different room it was
actually really helpful um but I mean
obviously if you have people that you
need be into contact with obviously keep
your phone with you
okay let's stick this
here
[Music]
okay
is
[Music]
this is like your stereotypical pop song
if I've ever heard it okay let's get
started uh this is let's just keep it
with the piano honestly this is going to
be just keep things simpler um the only
thing that could make this more
stereotypical is if I added rain so
let's do that um let's go to recordings
no no just kidding not there
um where is it my samples rendered
[Music]
also if you notice I don't talk a lot
when I produce this is uh the problem
every almost every single time I
recorded this is that uh I found that I
literally barely talk when I'm trying to
make music so when I start explaining I
actually do worse so that being said uh
if I'm quiet for most of the time uh the
second half is going to be more me
explaining this as I said before so
that's why I'm trying to separate in my
head that way I can focus on just making
good music okay let's add another
Labs no just kidding it's going to
be I need like a
really really electric
guitar very
[Music]
electric come
on that was loud
oh these are Bas guitars I'm
[Music]
blind
[Applause]
[Music]
it's like
to it's called like
aggressive
[Music]
[Applause]
for
[Music]
I need like a a bass guitar here that's
going to just be in the background and
kind of
[Music]
oh that's nice I like that
one you you'll hear my idea in a second
here I'm just going to
go there we
go
I
[Applause]
[Music]
m
this B is
like I was a little too
[Music]
um that was super cool I literally just
accidentally hit the Z key on my
keyboard with the the clap and it
sounded so cool hold on that could be
like a snare sample
right ooh
complete accident okay let's keep
going um
140 I like that a
[Music]
lot using samples cuz I have to Speed it
along here otherwise I wouldn't make my
own own drum right
[Music]
now okay I want to see what key we're in
1 billion per so I'm going to take the
chords here paste in the melody and see
what it tells me a Maj for sure okay for
sure for sure a
Maj okay I can see if I have a vocal and
aart major and waste a little bit of
time yeah I'm going to do that okay
let's go to ad adsr sample manager I
can't remember if I already explained
this because I know I for sure did in
the first first tutorial but I mean the
first attempt of this but I don't know
if I have used this yet so I'm just
going to look up another air
major it's crazy like when I actually
just focus on making music and like and
not explaining everything I swear I make
like 10 times better stuff okay I'm
going to look up
vocal there's literally only one vocal
in each chart
[Music]
maybe I don't really like
it put a major as well and I'll also
do I want multiple multiple
keys it's fine could be a different key
it's not big
[Music]
deal that could be cool if I pitch it
down and like you couldn't really
tell so it needs to be like
that
[Music]
oh
w
[Music]
a
okay so I have that so far uh okay I'm
going to check my time no I'm not going
to check my time I'm not going to cheat
all right Focus your you need to make
some type of drop some type
[Music]
of
okay I already have an idea I have an
idea okay so we're at 140
BPM I'm not even going to make a buildup
straight up just going to go like just
like that so it's literally going to
stop right on
this I need to get rid of that tiny
little H hit right
[Music]
there
oh that kind of sounds dope like if you
have it
[Music]
like
okay this is going to go this is this is
going to be a little bit crazy because
I'm just
GNA I need a kick that just hits hard
just a just an absolutely devastating
kick like because I'm going to make
something something
loud
here need a
kick manager this is the
best like how hard kick is like the
least hard oh that's CU it's stretching
the
sample whoops
okay that's yeah that's a lot um no too
too
much
o was this a I just I just want the one
kick and then I need a snare that's
like give me a
[Music]
snare
I need 808 808
that's thick I'm going use this one
[Music]
sampler oh this is the same 808 I made
that that mixer track for
bet
uh speed interest in speed use
[Music]
speed
oo no just to go
like
[Music]
okay so that's cool I like this a lot
so I need um some type of the cord's
going to hit like on the Dow beat like
this make unique and I need
to no I made it oh wait that's fine
that's not a big deal
okay let's think let's use Surge and I'm
going to pick some type of cords that
are
like Keys artificial
[Music]
okay um
let could be
interesting uh let's use that
sure just got to hurry up hurry up H up
hurry up don't have I don't I have zero
clue on how much time I have right
now zero clue I'm just going to go like
this and then I want it to just be like
[Music]
that it's so loud I need to add like
a I don't want to add a eliminer to my
master let me just turn it
[Music]
down
okay there should be absolutely zero
delay on this and then there needs to be
zero Reverb on this
too and then I also need this to have
like no release Turn
[Music]
Up
oh that's needs a little bit more
[Music]
decay
okay I need some type of lead on top of
here that's
like something um
I don't really have
anything I don't think maybe like a do I
have a preset maybe that sounds
good oh that's pretty
cool yeah
perfect come on fast speed
no
[Music]
this needs
like
[Music]
w
it's just so
[Music]
bad
okay
[Music]
for
okay so so far we have a fairly boring
is like okay so we have like an
[Music]
intro I can imagine a vocal
here I don't actually normally make
hip-hop so this is like really
interesting I actually don't know what
to do after this like I could try to
make a drop um but I started at 140 BPM
so it's like weird like can't do
house
um let's see I really want to look at my
timer but I know I'm not supposed to
okay
I guess I
[Music]
could okay I'm going to take a second to
just sit back and like think about this
while I listen to
[Music]
it
I think a vocal would really help me
right now come up with ideas I usually
what I do is I'll have like kind of like
a base idea like this send it to a
vocalist and then as soon as I get it
back I like have a billion ideas this
it's without a vocal it's hard sometimes
to think about like what to do next um
also I think the timer definitely makes
me it's harder to focus on like just
like ideas and stuff because you're like
you don't want to waste time
[Music]
um since this is
so unique in a way I don't really know
how the arrangement is supposed to go I
mean I guess I could strip it down even
more in the beginning I could like move
this forward just have
[Music]
this do something like that
and then you could literally just fade
it in over
[Music]
time
that's
clean you know you know it is um okay so
I got that would also kind of sound cool
[Music]
here
the chords okay so sometimes this is a
great uh a great point to sometimes you
need to know when to let your ideas die
cuz those chords are too low pitched I
knew they were I tried eqing them out
but you just notice that they just
weren't fitting in the mix and if
something's not fitting you just need to
cut it uh that just needs to be cut I
should have done that a long time ago so
let me listen to this
again
this is a boring sound I need to change
it uh but instead of changing it what
I'm going to do is I'm going to copy it
paste it mute it so I'm just going to
clone
it copy it paste it mute it and then I'm
going to go to this and then I can
change this without changing what I had
before
so
[Music]
yeah
n
[Music]
I could even turn back on
this
[Music]
um so my initial idea was that I was
going to be
like I should do this on piano because
if I show you guys on piano maybe it
would make more sense like what my
initial idea was so what I really wanted
to do
was I wanted to have it be like uh let
me sh for you by getting the melody as
well
here um so like my idea was it was going
to be
[Music]
like and then it would be
like
[Music]
not like that
like it's going to be like let
see
maybe
[Music]
Maybe not maybe not it's
fine I like the I like the kind of drops
where like it has cords and a lead but
they're not going at the same time
they're kind of like bouncing back and
forth that could be cool um I could look
at my time and then just call it or I
could keep going and if I keep going I'm
trying to figure out what I do
because
I can mess around with different
[Music]
Keys that's just way to low though now
so if I go sounds really cool for like
the first hit but then these these notes
are too low so I need to go back up
[Music]
to be real with you a sharp is a bit too
low I don't like to go below D sharp so
yeah D is kind of lowest I like to go
with my with my base dsh D that's
usually the lowest you can go without it
sounding like weird in the sub area I
don't know why it's just that is always
like that
um I don't know I don't
know I think it's good it's all right um
let's see the timer 13 minutes I'm just
going to stop it I'm going to stop it
right there and you know what we'll say
that that was a temp that was attempt
two got get back to my Apple CIO here
okay so let's talk about this for a
second
so um what I did was I I love doing this
little intro thing so what I do is I
take fic involver and I will put on my
master and put it to the pink noise
preset okay and then what that does is
essentially like if you
listen it blows everything out like in
terms of
the and it just creates this really warm
like I could honestly I could even do
this like this would probably make it
sound really good yeah like this this
right
[Music]
here
yeah yeah yeah like something like this
would be
perfect so you just kind of take these
two
[Music]
boom and it gives you like a hint of the
future like song of like what it's going
to be but it doesn't quite give it away
yet cuz it's like all reverbed out so
you can't really tell um I like starting
in with the Basse and the drums and
immediately off the start you want to
hook in your
listener another way we could hook in
The Listener here
is from the started here we could have a
a reverse that kind of goes into it so
um if I had like some type of uh what's
it called
sweep
uplifter perfect just something like
this very
[Music]
simple
see how much of a big difference that
makes
[Music]
just
uh every eight bars you want to add
something new this is constant so
honestly if I really want to make this
interesting I can probably take these
vocal things for right now and then just
leave it like
[Music]
this oh vocal thing and I think they
sound cool I also speed up the base here
um that's just to kind of give a little
bit more movement cuz you don't want to
ever stay like stagnant so like I can
make this super boring like I just keep
this the same too and then I like didn't
do anything new in this part other than
maybe add the
chords like it's fine but
[Applause]
this it just picks it up a notch I think
that this is huge um and then obviously
when I get into this
part this is just a huge producer life
hack if you just take out all the
volume right before the the drop it
makes it hit just that much harder so I
think that's that's cool um I want to
add in some saturation so I didn't
really add any saturation to
this that's like a million times better
already I can't believe I didn't do that
before um so yeah saturation to your uh
subbase it just adds those extra
harmonic so like we go into the sub face
right
[Music]
here
and for those of you saying that I my uh
my subbase is wide uh it is not actually
I'm using Bas Lane and what this does is
it widens certain bands of frequencies
over other bands so I'm actually
widening 500 htz right here on my sub
which is like really interesting because
it means that the subfrequencies are
going to stay low so like I could
literally take a midside EQ here like if
I go to Patcher and I go to uh
midside uh I made this preset and I'll
just straight up give you the uh guys
this for free uh this is so helpful and
I want you guys to have it um it so
basically
[Music]
like that's without the
wide hear the difference and then I can
literally take out the the lows and the
highs and it literally will sound no
different
[Music]
because
interesting huh I guess this 808 has a
little bit of width in the bottom that's
fine uh it still sounds good so I'm not
going to fuss over it too much I mean if
you really were worried about the 808
sounding wi in the bottom I guess you
could always put it
mon it still hits that's fine uh so yeah
I like I like the way that that sounds
so uh I also really like using that in
general just so I could put like a
Patcher here with my midside EQ preset
and if you do this um like I don't know
why I need to resave this preset where
the stereo is on the bottom uh basically
it splits the bands into a midside EQ
basically means that you can take the
the frequencies that are in mono and mix
them separately from the side
frequencies so that's what this bar is
right here so when I turn this wide it
makes things get wider and when I put it
this way it makes this mono so the
reason I have it like that is so that I
can mix these separately so like listen
[Music]
boring
way more interesting because I'm
boosting the highs and that just kind of
like tingles your ears okay
[Music]
so I would side chain the Basse but I've
noticed for a lot of hip-hop producers
they actually don't side chain the Basse
in the kick and for some reason it makes
it distort when the kick hits the base
and it sounds actually cooler uh so like
if I were to side chain this it would
just kind of lack that kind of uh messy
energy like where it just like
everything's just kind of hitting into
each other like that sounds cool for
hipop so I've kind of noticed this is
kind of a thing to
do if I take
[Music]
that and then I might
just oh that's the vocal what am I doing
where's
[Music]
the I might add it like a transpire on
this and then just
[Music]
boost add a little bit of
saturation
oh that's on the wrong thing so funny
that's fine I actually never put these
on mixture tracks that's
crazy let's put that on the mixure track
here we
go
[Music]
um
okay it's funny because I'm doing like
this one hour challenge but I literally
like just woke up I'm just going right
into it right in the morning uh I
usually produce like really late at
night I would like to hear when you guys
like to produce I I made some of my best
tracks at like 4:00 a.m. in the morning
it's hilarious obviously it's not good
for your sleep but I mean yeah um okay
so what else can we can we talk about
about this so uh we talked about the
progression and how we just want to kind
of increase energy over time but also
keep the listener engaged you want to
change things uh eight bars uh like keep
something changing all the way through
uh I think some other things that
intermediate producers I notic struggle
with is that yeah with one thing is
keeping things interesting um hooking
The Listener right away uh not having to
keep everything all the time so I don't
actually need this melody playing the
whole time I could actually take this
out
like and this would actually be really
good because what I can do is I could
have a singer on here and they could be
like singing here and just doing their
thing just have the melody coming in
that beginning part and then just have
the singer come in
[Music]
here I can't sing but if I would sing it
would yeah it probably wouldn't sound
good so
uh let's
see and then you bring in the melody
here and then you're like okay that
leads you into it and then I could
completely change the melody here too
like just for for instance like we could
literally
just change the whole thing right
here could be fun let's just
try
[Music]
never mind we're not going to
change
uh okay so another thing is that be
cognizant of What BPM you're in in what
kind of stuff that you're making because
obviously like I can't make house at 140
so like just keep it consistent in terms
of like what you're trying to do I think
that that's uh some people like they'll
don't change to BPM during your track
it's confusing for The Listener
um like I would stick to like kind of
one whole idea uh per track if you have
like four ideas going on in a track like
it's going to just confuse the listener
so um I wasn't doing anything crazy here
uh I started making hip-hop because I
was at 140 and I just stuck with it I
didn't change BPM I could have I could
have like maybe I could like turn it
down
to I don't really want to do that
because I stretch everything but that's
fine just leave it how it is uh I'm
trying to think it's it's also harder
for me to give advice with hip-hop music
because I don't actually make a lot of
it uh I make a lot of future balance in
like different uh EDM genres but I've
been trying to do more hip-hop because
it's it's it's a lot of fun to produce
um so let me let me think
typically
what you saw me uh mess around with
these vocal samples uh don't look at
something immediately and just go like
no try to see like the potential and
like things that you could use so you
saw the vocal s pi and you're probably
like e that does not fit at all but I
heard something in there and I was able
to pull it out to make something kind of
cool so like now we have
this and that adds a huge just like
background
element also another thing is that
notice how I just because I found
something cool I didn't have to use it
constant l so like this crush this was
like this little uh um this thing that
like uh I forgot what what the term is
called but it has a certain effect on
the vocals that I liked but I didn't
want it the whole
time see it's not
there and doing these kind of things
where you don't do it all the time adds
a lot of progression to your uh to your
music so like taking out the rain sounds
in in the drop here if I kept them
in
it's just kind of more going on if I
take it
out it just has that more of that drop
in feel where like you're hearing a lots
of sound
[Music]
here I could honestly I
could you could even do like a fake out
there there's so many potential things
you could do but once you like kind of
like suck everything out once it's like
it's all like sustained and then like
you can just take cut everything and
then it hits so much harder so uh that's
that's one huge thing uh one thing I
didn't do which I could show you guys is
if a really cool trick basically you're
going to go to your master create an
automation clip and then create one
automation clip on on the stereo as well
and then what you do is for the stereo
separation you're going to put it up
like just maybe like halfway and then
for the volume you're going to go down
like three
Deb do that do that and
then check this
out
[Music]
okay that might be a little bit too much
on the volume side let me one
sec go like right
here you don't want to do the volume too
much on the master but just as the
[Music]
effect everything kind of goes lower and
like more in in your
headphones and then it like widens out
last second it's super cool I love doing
that so that's another cool trick that
you guys can
do um
let's see for 1 hour challenge or I
guess like a 50 minute 45 minute I mean
I didn't really I wasn't really
producing the last 5 minutes I was kind
of just thinking
uh I guess yeah uh don't be afraid to
use Loops right here I just wanted to
save time and it was a cool idea and it
sounded nice so I just kept it in there
it's not a big deal um using Loops can
just give you a lot of creativity and
freedom free up the mind to do other
ideas um let's see here I have like AAR
major I could add in like other stuff so
like let's find another sample that
sounds cool with this so I go back to
adsr sample manager and I'm just going
to repeat this part right
here and then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to go only on loops and I'm
only going to search up a major samples
and just literally play them with the
song and this can lead to all kinds of
[Music]
ideas
H this sounds interesting I know it
doesn't fit in how it is but I think
like if I like let me show you an
example something so like let's say I
have some a sample that doesn't quite
fit and you can do things to make it fit
sometimes so like I can take
out so like maybe that doesn't work but
maybe I can like
take this and like pitch it
[Music]
up never know just do something like
that maybe not I I always like to check
so sometimes I'll just throw samples in
there and like sometimes you get lucky
and you're like oh wow that sounded like
perfect and then you can just keep it as
like a background element or just like
uh just something for uh one half of the
arrangement so um don't uh if you ever
are like looking for new ideas and
you're just like I'm stuck at this like
try throwing in a sample or two and just
see like if it spark some idea and even
if you don't use the sample you can
always use it to make something else
that's similar or like that you think
would lead to a cooler idea so uh that's
like another cool trick I'm trying to
like I think one huge thing for uh
moving from the kind of beginner
intermediate to Advanced stages is that
you need uh need to feel more
comfortable working faster so you
probably saw in this my workflow was 10
times faster than my beginner tutorial
and that's because I wasn't limited by
having to explain every single thing I
did I'm just kind of assuming that you
guys already know what you're doing so I
could just zoom through all this like
like just click through everything and
even though I'm going quickly if you
watch How I go quickly then you are able
to probably copy me later and then
that'll help you guys improve as well so
uh I'm trying a different method of uh
just basically teaching a lesson here
because uh the first way I did it in the
beginner of tutorial I thought was
helpful if you'd never produced before
but if you are producing I think trying
to think about the things that you don't
know like there's a lot of things that
you just don't know and uh basically how
it was for me is I look up tutorials and
I try to find things that they could
inform me on that I didn't already know
but a lot of times they were just
telling me how to do something rather
than telling me the why behind it and so
I like like explaining the reasons of
why I do things rather than giving you
like a technical explanation a lot of
times because that'll be more beneficial
to you in the long run so let me give
you a good example of this I could like
one technical thing I told you guys was
about the involver trick and that's
practical you could use that in your own
um but it doesn't tell you why I did I
did this and if I explain why I did it
if I if I say okay I want to give
contrast from the inro of the song and
then draw the listener's ear in right as
the song starts so that it starts off on
the beat like immediately so I have no
kicks no drums going on
here and then
immediately that's going to draw The
Listener in okay in the first five
seconds of the song uh it's the same
idea here where I take out
everything this part and then this
beginning part are the same thing
they're the same concept uh and doing it
right before the transition from the
bridge the chorus and from the I mean
not the bridge my bad um the buildups to
the chorus and the intro to or I guess
the starting intro to the intro gives
that same effect of the the why behind
it would be I want to uh create a not
necessarily a surprise but something
that catches the the listener's ear
immediately so that's something to think
about so I think that that that's the
reason I like doing this convolver trip
for instance another way I could help
you guys with like a technical thing
balance with the reason for why I do it
is uh I think I explained that with the
with the crush technique is that I
didn't we're not just I'm not teaching
you just oh use Crush it's cool fore
plugin and if you do this effect it's
cool uh basically I was like okay well
once you find something cool um I didn't
want to do it all the time because it
doesn't keep the song interesting so
keeping the song flowing and moving so
that the listener wants to keep
listening uh you want to add change
throughout your song So if I just kept
this the same the whole time it would
just sound it wouldn't be bad it just
would be less interesting so if I mean
if I just keep it
[Music]
on
I mean it doesn't the weird thing is
that there's a lot of things in music
that don't sound bad so you can leave
them like that but then until you do
something different that sounds better
then you're like oh that sounds even
better and that's why uh I highly
recommend that you guys collaborate with
artists find people your skill level and
then just ask them you have to kind of
just take a leap and just be like hey
man you want to make you want to make a
song and then just do that and I think
that that would be it would be so
helpful for you guys I remember I just
join a bunch of discords and I'd
literally just sit in a Discord with
like five people and we'd all make music
like dead silent while we're making
music and then we'd like DM each other
later like hey you want to make a song
and then that's that's literally like
how I learned how to make music I think
it's one of the best ways too because
you're matching people with your skill
level and then working with them uh will
help you all improve um as you keep
practicing together uh and then what you
want to do is just keep making friends
with better and better producers and
then just keep working up and building
your skills and slowly by slowly you'll
meet uh like people that are a little
bit better than you that maybe have
already released on a label and they'll
want to uh be with you I mean if you're
just a nice person and you're fun to
hang out with um it's really easy to
make friends with uh good producers and
just uh learning and get better so I
think one super underrated tip where
like you might go on YouTube and you
might look up for like tutorials on how
to become a better producer and they
might give you all these mixing
techniques and I did I I told you about
Patcher and midside Q is massive it's so
helpful but it's not going to turn you
into professional just knowing midside
of Q what will really turn you into
professional is making connections with
artists that are uh bigger than you and
just uh having having your name out
there a little bit more and just knowing
people um and I mean if that if that's
your goal that's that's really the what
you want to do um there was this really
good artist and he gave me advice he
basically told me he said the difference
between um a good producer and a great
producer has uh how did he put it he
didn't say he basically said um it
doesn't have to do with technical
ability or anything he said I've seen uh
good artists that are way more
technically better than professional
artists I've seen professional artists
that
are vice versa you know um but his his
point was is that it's not necessarily
about the technical ability but also the
knowledge and the skills of uh being an
artist are different than just technical
ability so knowing music theory doesn't
make you a professional artist uh
knowing the whole all of FO Studio
doesn't make you a professional artist
and so that's why I would say that I I
am a professional music producer but I
wouldn't say I'm a professional artists
um there's a big difference because I I
just haven't released music so I can't
really be considered a professional
artist even though I've made hundreds
and hundreds of songs and I made songs
for clients and I've done all that I I
wouldn't be technically considered a
professional musician simply because I
don't have professionally released Songs
so I would really like to do that um but
obviously just haven't figured out
exactly what Nisha I want to uh start in
and what kind of music I want to make I
mean even you saw even this one hour
challenge I wasn't really sure what I
was making it like turned into hip-hop
but I don't really like to make hip-hop
all that often so um I digress uh so
just trying to think of more Advanced
Techniques uh in the last uh attempt of
this this is attempt two in the last
attempt what I did was I actually used
Edison to record a sound desize session
so like let me let me show you what I
mean I'll literally stick Edison on my
master
here
uh actually let's save this and just go
out of the file I think that I pretty
much showed also happy accidents by Ross
moment when I accidentally hit my
keyboard and made that cool
snare
that was so cool I'm like so happy I did
that that was like such an awesome I'm
going to do that my other tracks I
didn't even know that that could sound
that cool is this just on
c yeah it literally is it's just one
octave below so if I put these on the
same yeah that's so cool that's
hilarious um okay so let's go into a new
template I just want to show you guys
some stuff so this that was kind of like
my reflection on the one hour challenge
uh I also just want to show you guys
other Advanced Techniques that I think
would be really helpful to you so I
think I'm not sure what you guys are
necessarily expecting I know I've been
getting emails almost every day asking
me to do a second
course and um if I systematically went
through every Advanced technique in FL
Studio we'd probably be here for like
about a year because there are so many
different things that I could go through
and all of them are important so I'm
trying to give you guys the tools that
will enable you like uh so instead of
giving you fish I want to teach you how
to fish obviously so I want to teach you
the methods that I use to become a good
Producer instead of just telling you
facts or telling you stuff that is
helpful but you're probably not going to
remember because this is a long tutorial
it's going to be like probably over an
hour and so I want to give you a ways of
becoming better that way you can become
better artist on your own instead of uh
watching tons of tutorials and then
forgetting everything and that and still
being the same level producer which
definitely happens um so I don't want to
trick you guys with tutorials I want to
help you improve so one thing that could
help you improve is by simply just going
on your master sticking an Edison on
there that's aor not fector it's a cool
plugin but not what I was looking for
Edison just going to hit record and I'm
literally just going to go to vital and
then as soon as you just start messing
around you're recording in here so I can
literally just find
some like
[Music]
same
so we got
[Music]
like so as you can see I like just was
messing around for a second and then
uh where am I I need this so you can
take this right and I can actually drag
and drop this immediately by clicking
this button right here and into the
[Music]
playlist and I could take something like
this right I could copy that I like
that I could literally copy and make
this use a unique sample save this it's
going to go into uh my backup and then I
can go to tww samples I go
to where is it my samples render
and then this is called September 13th
Part One blah blah blah I could just
call
this du du du and then I could save it
and then I could go back to our project
file that we just
in and then I could literally just pull
let me show you guys an
example because that that was what an
AAR major and I just did that in C major
so need to go one two steps down
and then whole
octop okay that so I have this right
here I'll just literally go to my
samples my
samples just refresh it
du okay so I just need to pitch it down
twice go up
once
stretch maybe like stretch it so it fits
in
like
I have no idea like
just it doesn't really sound that good
but uh just for instance you could see
how this could be cool like where you
just have a recording where you could
just go in Edison sound design cut a
small part of it and then use that in
your tracks so you never really know
what you'll get like just messing around
and a lot of times you miss it like
you're like oh that sound is so cool and
then you like don't have it every time
your sound design it just hit Edison and
you'll literally never miss any of those
moments and then what you can do is you
can have a folder like this where you
just save all of those recordings of
your Edison sound design and then you'll
have all of those as your own library of
samples and I started doing this my
computer unfortunately crashed so like I
obviously I didn't make this Advanced
tutorial for another eight months so the
reason being for that was for a lot of
reasons one my computer completely
failed I lost everything and I like
restart from scratch and then that was
like really difficult um the second
thing was more of a personal uh thing
with a relationship so like I was I was
like really down so I just was not in
the mental state to like make another
thing so I was tough and then so after I
got I kind of refixed my computer got a
new laptop got a new setup obviously
well you can't see because I'm doing a
green screen but I'm in a new place
right now I got a new microphone I got
new everything that took about like
two-ish months then by that time I was
thinking about doing doing personal
courses uh for the people in the first
beginner class but I decided not to
because I just wasn't sure of how much
value I could provide uh the big thing
with that was that I was thinking okay
well if I do personal courses for you
guys how much value is that really
giving to and I figured okay it's
actually not providing that much value
because I wouldn't want to give knowing
what I know now I wouldn't have wanted
somebody to I wouldn't have wanted to
pay somebody to give me just one-on-one
advice that wasn't I don't think that
that would be as helpful uh what I do
think would be helpful was teaching the
and the reasons of why I do things for
free uh and I think that's more helpful
than me doing paid courses so that's why
I never offered uh paid courses um that
being said another reason I really
couldn't do the course for so long was
because uh I literally just couldn't
like I needed to work I just didn't have
time so the only reason I'm I'm doing
this now is because I a I wanted to make
a second installment because I get
emails every single day and then I also
I've always wanted to do music uh to
some capacity as as like a career so I
mean uh obviously I don't think I can do
that for a while I would have to kind of
establish myself a little bit more um
but I am going to be releasing the FP
for this completely free um and I
believe yeah all the samples I used are
are free so uh you can pick up all these
samples for free as well and I'll just
release this FP in the
description and you could pick that up
um if you'd also like I'm also going to
leave uh under a comment I'm just going
to have uh just my my YouTube channel
and I'm also going to have uh like
hopefully some type of website by time
this course is out or some link uh to
like a pack which you could use to to
help me and also help your Productions
as well just improve uh what you're
making cuz I know it could be hard to
find samples out there it can be hard uh
so I'll probably have samples and
presets I'm not exactly sure what I'm
going to do for that by the time this
course is out but I'll have something
something available and then also
something for free for you guys so if
You' like to support me in that way
hopefully I can make you guys more
tutorials and I'd love to start making
more tutorials on my channel as well um
I don't know how much I have to add to
this uh I was going to do this in
collaboration with another artist and uh
he was going to do vocals so what I
might do is if this tutorial keeps going
then that means that he's collaborating
with me and if he's collaborating with
me then maybe I could do a second part
of this tutorial where we have the
vocals on top and we try to finish the
track together and in that case I'll get
back to you guys and maybe I'll do a
part two and maybe we'll just keep this
as a shorter version of the tutorial and
just see how it goes so with that being
said thanks so much for your guys
support I'm glad that these tutorials
are helping and I know this is a little
bit different format and maybe a little
less of what you were expecting uh in
terms of the last tutorial I did was a
lot more methodical this didn't really
have chapters it was more of just off
the cuff like okay let's make this
Challenge and then let's explain what I
was doing uh so I hope you found value
in this as well I know it's a bit
different um but thanks for watching
guys and uh I'll see you
[Music]
soon all right we're here in the actual
project after the 1 hour challenge and
now I'm going to show you guys what this
looks like so to me I uh it was not
loading some some of the things which is
unfortunate but I'm going just going to
play it the way it is and we'll try to
go through as much as we can so a lot of
this stuff looks exactly the same as my
1 hour challenge obviously I absolutely
love what he did here it looks so
awesome that he like uh color
coordinated everything I love that um
props I thank you blend a base uh so we
got and I feel like I can skip a lot of
this because it's just the same as
winner challenge uh let's go to the to
the part that he did stuff
with obviously this is not sound very
good I'm not sure why it's not loading
some of the plugins right so it's not
going to sound very nice
but so you can see he actually chopped
up uh both the samples here and just
made some interesting uh rhythmic and
Pitch patterns to change it up
here the funny thing is when I first uh
saw him doing this I'm like this is kind
of hard to follow and then after now I'm
like completely vibing with it and it's
awesome and I was wrong again all uh
then he did this super cool thing where
he he sampled and then used the channel
pitch or the sample to make this one of
the coolest things I've I've heard I
don't know this is so cool to
me that is such a that that is that is
swag that's like the way that that comes
into this
bar that is so cool as soon as I heard
him do that I was like okay that's sick
um but yeah it's just uh changing the
pitch of and he used the song to sample
itself and then yeah it's very very
creative um right here we have a really
cool uh chord
[Music]
preset and it's kind of playing with
everything
[Music]
else I really wanted to use a drop and
make something with this I just never
got the the chance to since the project
wasn't working in my favor unfortunately
but uh let's go so he I like how he also
moves down further and further uh so not
everything's on the same level it's kind
of interesting uh let's go here see what
he did here
in the front
scene to the and
you so we see the way that he did his
voice was super interesting so he
actually used his voice as a instrument
uh and the instrument isn't loing for me
but he actually used his voice and then
uh he forgot I forgot the way that he
explained it but it's so interesting he
actually essentially used it as a sample
and then uh played chords with it uh
under his own voice this is
very
so you can hear that playing over and
over again that's his voice and then he
has
going oh the chords are working so yeah
this is his voice you can hear
it it's like playing his AC C
capella and that's him saying it always
on the
[Music]
run Horizons behind me looking at the
dashboard fast FL D so you can see that
we keep the vocals mostly mono and we
have different uh different vocal layers
going to different vocal buses and then
eqing those uh separately is the way
that he did it which is the same way
that I do my vocals as well uh and then
you can just apply effects those
different um side pan vocals and the
ones that are in the center and
obviously the ones that make up the
chords so that you can have a a very
cohesive vocal so it's not just a a
vocal is almost never just one take it's
usually like uh 10 different takes and
then uh doing slightly different things
with each one of those to complement the
whole so that's usually the way that uh
vocals are done so you should never
expect to just like record vocals into a
mic and then just be like good for your
song like that almost never happens I
usually tons of vocal samples and that's
how that
works I think I accidentally changed
some of this a way I was like messing
around earlier that's pretty
funny this part is so cool I love how it
like drops out into this giant opens up
into this like rebb area where like it
just uh kind of expands the song and
then it there's no rhythmic element
going on so it's just kind of floaty and
then it turns into a buildup which I
thought was one of the most creative
ways to go from an like an ambient track
from hipop and then into like a buildup
it just shows like uh when you collab
with people you're going to come up with
ideas that are like greater than some of
the parts because I know for a fact like
when I sent him this track he doesn't
make stuff like this so like the stuff
that he's going to make out of it is
going to be super interesting um and
just be different so it's it's really
it's really cool and fun to collab and
that's another reason why you should
join
the
[Music]
and then he as you can hear that this
riter is slowly getting
[Music]
louder in my opinion in my opinion this
is is my opinion I think that that it
probably should have hit here it just
goes for a little bit extra and I think
that lose a little bit of energy that's
just my thoughts but overall still
really
dope
still
[Music]
really and then he completely made this
part this wasn't me at all he's just
like I want to make this part I'm like
all go for it and then he did it was it
was super sick uh and I've never heard
him make this type of house music before
really interesting we usually make like
future balance or something this is this
is super cool uh but yeah and then
obviously he has the lead playing in the
background I'm trying to figure out
where the lead is is it this no it's a
high hat it must be this
[Music]
right I am not seeing the lead I might
just be blind but anyways very cool um I
don't have a ton to add as I said the
project didn't totally load for me so
it's a little bit unfortunate but um
yeah this is this is the project uh if
you were curious and seeing a little bit
like what it looks like this is what it
ended up turning out like um this was
going to be actually the whole uh
Advanced tutorial I was going to go over
this entire track uh after the 1 hour
challenge so I just wanted to do a
shorter version of that since this is
already getting pretty long with the
other uh version of the course that I
did and I have recorded many versions of
this course but hopefully you liked this
version and without further Ado I hope
that you are able to create your own
songs out of this and that this was
helpful uh into improving your
Productions in the future so without
further Ado I'll see you later and you
can uh see if you want to see more of me
I'm going to be making YouTube videos
I'll see you there
[Music]
bye one of the last things I wanted to
go over was one of the most Advanced
Techniques I think uh that I can teach
you and it's so something so funny
because a lot of people learned this
really early and some people don't learn
it for a very long time for some reason
uh and it's not really that complicated
and some people might laugh and be like
oh it's so simple like either why didn't
I think of that before or why are you
just telling them this now like this is
not like an advanced tip but it will
help you become an advanced producer and
that's simply using reference tracks uh
this is so important so I used uh I I
can't play this song because it'll get
copyrighted but I used this as uh there
was an advertising agency that wanted me
to make a song similar to this so I uh
took the song and I re pretty much
remade it and just change the Melodies
and instruments to make my own version
of it with kind of the same energy uh so
this was the initial track uh I was able
to use an AI to split the vocals from
the instrumental and then I had the
instrumental in my track and tried to
make something really similar so you
guys can listen to this song on your own
time and then come back here and listen
to what this sounds
like in comparison to the original
track
[Music]
e
the funny thing about this is I also
made this in like an hour like an hour
and a half and I had to make it really
quickly because of deadlines and so
deadlines are could be a huge motivator
for making things really quickly and uh
this is just one example of how I had a
reference track and how I was able to
use that to try to copy and make
something similar to that and then do my
own take on it so I use the arrangement
as inspiration I use the type of
instruments they were using as
inspiration and ultimately it can help
you uh expand your music production what
is it like repertoire because uh by
trying to figure out how other artists
did things it will help you realize
things that you've never tried before
and uh open you up to new ways of making
things so for instance something like
this guitar section I had never made
anything like this before and I thought
it sounded really
[Music]
interesting like I do not make guitar
patterns usually like this so this was
the
[Music]
inspiration
so I just thought it turned out pretty
interesting so uh and it really fit the
track so stuff like that and then I
never used to make guitar Melodies that
kind of would like this all of it was
really interesting and a learning
experience for me and while I don't
really make this type of music and I'm
not super like impressed by like the
final result I'm like it's all right
it's like not something I release or
work on really any longer um but I know
that it's something that that um that
they were looking for so this is
something that they wanted not something
that I wanted so I was uh making it for
a different reason there but uh yeah use
reference tracks and try to make make it
as close to as you can uh and just kind
of it'll help you fix uh learn how to
make your mixes better because you'll be
listening to professionals and their
mixes and how to make your instrumentals
and so that's uh one huge tip is just
using reference tracks and then
following and using their Arrangement as
a uh inspiration for your own
arrangement for your track uh and that
can help you and save you so much time
because if you don't know how to arrange
your music because you're not listening
to music that other people are listening
to then your music is going to be
chaotic and it's be hard to follow and
yeah it'll just be difficult and you
might think oh I don't want like any
limitations I don't want anything to
stunt my creativity it's like your
creativity only works if you have
limitations first to break you can't go
outside of a box if there is no box so
that's why reference tracks are so
helpful because they give you something
that you can work off of and be creative
with so hopefully that that was helpful
and I just wanted to quickly show this
um and I don't know how much more I have
to show you guys uh I really thought I
went over a lot for this Advanced
tutorial and I know it's not as
comprehensive and maybe some people
wanted um so maybe I just go a kind of
speed through all the tips before we go
out basically every tip that comes to my
mind I'm this is going to be like a
supercharged tip section where I just
zoom through a million tips that I can
think of uh and then we'll close it out
the last thing that I'd like to say is
that I do have a website with my sing
pack and I think that this would be
super helpful for you guys and the
reason that uh I'm even offering the SLE
pack and I think that would be useful
for to you guys is because I am updating
it um every time I make some new music
or I make uh something I'm adding uh
different things that I've made to that
sample pack for free so as you buy it
you can always go back and download the
new samples I add so so there's almost
no sample packs that do that where you
just buy it and there's always new
samples for you every time you open it
up that's super cool I think so uh I
just want to let you guys know that's
Tristan wil cox. us with twls and then I
also off all my patreon I offer personal
courses uh one-on-one and I give you
feedback at different uh tiers you can
see that whatever works for you to help
support uh support me and then I also
make YouTube videos for free so uh you
guys can see my Productions on my own
music and hopefully I can share uh some
knowledge and just help you guys grow in
your music producer Journey so without
further ado we are going to zoom through
all the tips starting now so one thing
that you can do is if you have sample
packs I would go through all your
samples and make one Consolidated uh
sample pack with all your favorite
samples out of different sample packs
you use rather than having hundreds of
sample packs in your browser so that's
something that I did and this is what I
came up with I had drums extra sample
packs effects uh yeah so this got kind
of messy pretty quickly but essentially
you'll have all the folders full of
things that you have so I have drum and
this says buildup Loop claps fills drum
loops and then you can see that these
come from all sorts of different sample
packs I've downloaded in the past and
samples that I've made and so what this
does is effectively consolidates all
your sample packs uh into one sample
pack rather than having to go through a
million sample packs to find the ones
that you want uh so this is I think very
helpful um another thing that you can do
is just save literally everything save
your projects save your fops export your
fops name your FPS and your exported of
the FP the same thing so that if I
search for the FP I can find the
exported file in case that FP gets
corrupted save your work see where
you've been I have not saved a lot of my
work and that's why I lost a lot of my
work so just something that I want to
know uh so you always want to be saving
your stuff always want to be making
backups of your stuff uh something that
you can do is if you have any preset you
can save your presets go here go file go
save as preset and then save that and
then once you save that name it the same
thing uh so whatever I name it here name
that the same thing that you save it's
it's a mixer chain as well so whatever
the mixer chain is called you want to
save those as the same name so when you
open up both you can up both of those
together uh something cool that you can
always mess around with is that if
you're in the piano roll you can always
go to this down arrow key go to view go
to scale highlighting and you can put it
on automatic and it will help you
highlight different uh parts of the
scale that you're looking for or you can
change it to the scale of the reference
track that you're working on or you can
just make it some interesting scale and
just mess around with that and see what
kind of uh creative ideas and Melodies
that helps you come up with something I
would really recommend uh is that when
you you are uh editing your notes you
want allow resizing from left to be
enabled this is super annoying when it's
off so I highly recommend that you have
that enabled if you want uh a window on
one of your syns to be open make sure
that you on this arrow you click
detached and it will stay open as you're
working uh and that's really helpful for
like if I want to be sound designing
this and changing notes I can't do both
at the same time unless this window is
detached okay so that just means that
this changing things here doesn't affect
this window uh and then if I want to un
attach this you'll see what happens if I
change something here it'll disappear
that window so that you can fully Focus
so that's just another thing if you are
afraid of making a change in your track
and you don't want it to affect uh your
overall production you can go to file
you can go to save as new version and
what that will do is it will essentially
make the a copy of that flp as a new
version so you can make any changes that
you want and still have your old version
of the flp without changing anything
there um something that you can do is
that if uh you have some there's this
weird automation glitch that happens uh
but sometimes you need uh you'll have a
mixer track uh that looks like this
where um it just no matter what you do
it's always stuck at zero what you want
to do to fix this is turn this mixture
track all the way up right click it and
then go initiate song with this position
once you do that it will reset that one
uh if it's still not working uh you can
always reset the entire uh preset by or
reset the entire mixer Chain by clicking
reset select trct the
default if you want to save and copy
effects from one mixture chain to
another what you can do is you can right
click and you can go to file and you go
to save mixure track St as if you click
and hold and drag you can drag that to
any other mixer chain and unlet go on
that and will copy everything about that
to the new mixer chain that is so cool
to me that you can do that um another
thing that you can do is that if you'd
like to make a slightly different um uh
lead like variant is that like let's say
I have a first drop and then I have a
second drop and I want to make a
different lead but it still fits in my
track I can actually just right click on
this and click clone and it will
duplicate uh that preset and then I can
make slight differences in that preset
so that I have two different uh things
that are but both similar in style if
that makes sense so hopefully that
wasn't too complicated um what's another
thing uh let's think I'm running out
steam I I was like I was on a roll with
with with those tips let's see if I can
uh think of anymore um if you have uh
this uh magnet on on different things it
can really screw you up so I have mine
on cell and that's what it's selected on
so when I move things around it always
clicks to the nearest cell if I had this
on none it would just slide kind of all
around and be very unpredictable so I
have it on cell that way when I click it
um it properly uh aligns to the grid the
way you would imagine it would um
something that you can do is that if I
left click and hold alt I
can I can uh I can uh play patterns in
the
[Music]
track and then you can also do this on a
different level inside inside the piano
roll without playing through the entire
thing so if you just want to hear what
this chord sounds like at the end
without having to play the hold pattern
over again alt right
click and you can drag through to see
what that sounds like um one thing uh
another tip that I have which I shared
in the very beginning of the course is
any knob that you see in a third party
Plugin or in a normal plugin you can
click and you can automate if you go
here and I Chang something I can go to
what I changed up here right click it
and go create automation clip and it
will literally create an automation clip
for whatever I just moved last um as you
can see that create an automation clip
for that five band frequency and that's
how you can make automations for
literally anything that you change in
the entire uh in the entire uh
program um other things that I can
recommend uh in the sampler uh if you
want to uh play like an instrument uh
you can't just do it by dragging and
dropping the sample in here what you'd
actually have to do is go to your
channel Rack open up something called
the sampler here
and once you open up that sampler and
drag and drop a sample onto that let's
say actually I need actually like a one
shot and then I need to be like a synth
and then I'll drop that sampler into the
sample and that will give you the
envelope tool which you can use to to
change the envelope of your
sound
and then I use the cross bait and this
will allow you to sustain whatever
instrument that you're playing over time
so if I put the cross bait all the way
up you can hear it's like still playing
a little bit which is really cool um
another thing that you can do is that if
you want it to slide you can go to this
wrench tool click mono click up and then
uh Max and then you can do one is what I
like to
do and then you can have it uh bending
like crazy like I showed you in the
beginning of the sound design course so
that's how you do that in the sampler um
something that you can do is if this
range for pitch isn't enough you can
just increase the range to 12 uh that'll
make it go up octave up or an octave
down and then you can automate the pitch
of that accordingly because you cannot
as far as I know automate this pitch
right here so that's just a quick tip
right there also did you know that the
volume here and the volume in here in
the channel rack are exactly the same so
you can see this thing changing with
this those are the same thing
FYI um trying to think of anything else
that I can think of if you take hold on
the sample you can also drag and then
drop it in the in the uh playlist as as
well so those are kind of they work
together as well in that way um if I
have a pattern that has multiple things
going on in it I can split it so like
let's say I have this chord progression
and it is in this melody here and I go
like here and I paste those chords and I
have these kind of on top of each other
I can go to this pattern I can right
click the pattern and click split by
Channel and then will pull out that and
then give me the guitar and that chord
separately in two different patterns so
you can use that for arranging um and
doing that um another cool thing that
you can do is in the top left corner of
this it gives you tons of settings for
the sampler uh for samples and for uh
your uh patterns so for instance I can
click chop and I can go uh different
things so I can do like beat Shuffle and
it will like completely change the way
this
[Music]
go and that completely changed the
melody because it chopped it up and the
same thing happens uh with loot base
samples too so if I go to Loop
and I go to like actually let me just
show you guys an example by literally
muting everything except for this and
then going to my own sample pack and
this will just be a little plug because
I'll show you one of the cooler samples
in my pack so we'll go to loops and go
to
other you can't tell me this doesn't
sound
[Music]
sick
it's so funny like I like I make stuff
like this and then like you guys see me
like when I'm working and trying to show
you guys how to music produce and I like
make like the most garbage stuff but
then like when I'm alone like sitting
it's like raining outside I'm like
making like music like this is so funny
it just depends on like the mood I'm in
and like different things to be it can
highly affect the way also how much
water you drink and what snacks you have
with you will affect different types of
music that you're making cool facts okay
so uh top left corner here I can go to
here and there's all sorts uh types of
settings like if I want to make another
sample that's um high pitched and the
other one low pitched but I want them to
play at the same time I could go to
click this make unique a sample and this
uh will not affect what I changed here
will not affect this so I can have a
play at the same
[Music]
time and then I could select both of
them at the same time and I could
actually make changes to both of them
simultaneously so then I could uh have
um CH I could chop it both the same way
and then I could like do something like
this
[Laughter]
[Music]
and that for some reason sounds very
cool so I might use that in some type of
track on day but uh yeah you could use
that that chop function and that was
just one of the functions here there's
so many different ones that you can do
and I haven't even messed with all of
them so apparently you can extract stems
from the sample uh I haven't even tried
this yet uh it's with the new FL
studio21 update they just did I forgot
which one but if you up I can extract
stems uh this feature needs to be
downloaded before it can be used
download now sure let's do
that that's so cool I've never used this
before so like it's just exciting like
you're just messing around you're just
looking at different things and you can
find all sorts of new stuff in Apple
Studio Poss things new that they're
adding so just going to download this
really quick and see what it does so
this is just the advanced production
process just randomly seeing what
happens when you click things uh and and
then not being afraid to see what
happens so let's do uh there's no vocals
I can just pull that out and let's
extract let's see what it does I'm
really
curious processing
processing I'm so curious if this going
to get all my samples out of this that
would blow me
away so does it just poop him out oh my
goodness it does how cool is
that
[Music]
and this is a
base that is so you can't tell me that's
not cool that is really cool like they
just added this too okay that's another
Advanced production technique extracting
your s your own from things from samples
how cool is that wow that is really cool
I honestly I don't even think that I
could show you a cool a cooler thing
let's end it off like that I know e just
added that I saw that and I hadn't used
it until then that is so cool okay I
think that's a great place to end it
I've gone over a lot of stuff and I
haven't even gone over over maybe like
5% of everything in this program it's
insane like if I was literally to do an
advanced tutorial front to back all
everything I could be here for like a
year like it's there's so much to do oh
it's so frustrating like I just want to
show you guys everything I want to I
want to help you guys and I know that I
can't do it all in one tutorial and
that's why I want to for the last time
say I making videos on my YouTube
channel now uh because a lot of people
have been asking me to and I'm going to
help you guys we're going to do
challenges I'm going to do like uh so
we'll all kinds of really neat
challenges uh in my Discord Community as
well that um I'm hoping will add more
fun and so you can find people to make
music with so if you don't have any
friends to make music with uh come join
my Discord uh community and we're all
going to make music together I'm going
to do challenges I'll be there too it's
not going to be one of those things
where I just won't be there I will be
there and I'll help you and if you're if
you want to join me uh making music then
just yeah join the channel join the
stuff and I just want to thank uh free
Cod camp for this opportunity again and
I absolutely love their Channel and they
helped me so much when I was in college
as well so I want to return the favor by
helping them uh by making a a tutorial
that could help everyone else so with
that being said thank you so much for
joining and I hope that you gathered at
least a little bit of information and
remember enjoy the process and have fun
producing
[Music]
peace